Right now,
here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're live.
We've done it faster this time than
ever.
We're getting better at it.
Less fuckups,
less hiccups.
Live from the compound.
Uh,
we started a little bit late today.
That was all my fault.
Brian was rocked and locked and loaded.
This time I just fucked up.
I was tired because I had to do the
feminine being show this morning and I
had to get up early because I have to
leave my house is kind of far from them.
What the fuck people that's gone down,
but just happy new year.
Uh,
Brian is all in a tizzy about the God
Damn Ipad and me.
I twittered that I don't need an ipad
because I'm a fucking man and I can
carry a goddamn backpack with a laptop
and I don't complain like a little
bitch.
And this seems like it's got less shit
than a laptop.
And if you're going to go like on an
airplane or something,
go somewhere.
You want to fucking laptop.
We want to be able to get on the
computer.
You want to be able to send someone to
real goddamn email or attach something
to it and send a real link.
Easy copy and paste old school.
You don't want some nutty fucking finger
things.
You have to shut up.
I want to fucking laptop and it's not
heavy.
I can take this goddamn thing anywhere.
They're so small now.
I mean the sin and the light.
This is.
I got to hit.
This is the 17 inch Mac book.
This thing is,
it's not heavy.
He put it in a backpack.
You're fine.
I don't need an IPAD,
Brian.
Well see,
I think that's the problem with a.
can everyone hear us okay before we
start getting really into it as the
microphone back where we are.
Not a well polished machine.
Some gentleman.
Now where's the time here?
I'll see if,
if we can hear ourselves.
This is.
If this was like real tv,
we'd be fun.
We'll see if we can hear ourselves.
Who we are.
We're,
yeah,
we're
good.
Alright,
so here's the thing.
What about that,
the whole that tablet.
Now the problem with the whole thing is
that Steve Jobs pretty much just bashed
net books at the beginning of the the
thing,
so it really set a nerve with a lot of
people,
meaning people are like,
what nipples vendor,
so he knows in his speech and his speech
that much
fan boy,
I'm not going to sit and watch you strut
around and talk about your fucking
computer.
I enjoy your stuff.
I think your iphone is a goddamn work
with are amazing.
If verizon had it,
it would be the greatest school in the
history of the universe,
but I can't use it as a phone.
I use it to me.
I have.
I carry two phones.
I carry a blackberry and verizon.
That's a fucking phone I can call
people.
It sucks.
It's terrible phone.
It's like a drunk iphone.
Like when you compare the two of them
together,
there's no comparison.
Like sometimes,
like I say,
if I call you and I have a little
picture for your face when I call you
and I go to call somebody else,
when I start calling somebody else,
your picture will show up and then it'll
change.
So it's like the things like,
oh,
I'm going to go on.
It's like it's dumb,
it's a dumb phone.
It's like it does what you want to,
but it takes like a couple extra seconds
and it stumbles this storm to.
Yeah,
the strong to the screen is awesome.
It's a nice big ass screen and I,
I liked that.
And the touchscreen's not too bad.
It's pretty easy to type the,
even this way in landscape mode,
it's good.
It's like,
it's weird.
It gives you a little feedback,
which really isn't necessary but it's
not bad.
And as a phone it's great,
but compared to the iphone was just
getting on the web.
It's just like,
like you're doing it in an old wooden
car,
you know,
it's just so clunky and stupid and zoom,
okay,
scroll this way and Oh,
come on.
Really what
you're saying is the best part about the
iphone is probably Internet and the
worst part is the worst part is clearly
I don't mind making calls on calls on
his bad ass,
just that,
but I just don't want.
Tea is just terrible.
It might be better in somebody's town,
you know,
for.
They've got more towers,
more GSM towers.
So they took the,
the,
the best part of the iphone and made it
a little bit bigger.
Yeah.
And they got rid of like no camera.
What the fuck?
Well here's the whole thing about this.
What I'm thinking now is I'm thinking,
all right,
I like my iphone,
but I only use it once in awhile.
I want something small to surf the net
and do basic shit with.
Oh,
I listen to this.
Say you're in a starbucks and some dude
comes in and starts spraying the place.
Okay.
And you want to be taking video,
right?
And you're on your little ipad thinking
you're a genius sipping on your lives.
Have two cameras have shit.
You not me.
You're just a regular dude.
Just as your digital camera.
You have us as an ipad and the
blackberry because he's not sold on
apple online.
He's online right there and he wants to
get online with his ipad and take video
and streaming to stream of this
happening and he can't do it because the
ipads a piece of shit.
Okay,
well listen to have a camera.
Well,
listen,
now,
one of the things that he in his space
logic,
here's my argument,
he said during the speech that it has a
port that is going to have accessories
to open it up to the universe.
Imagine having an hd camera hooked up to
the bottom and you just happened to be
streaming through starbucks,
like a fucking creep.
You can't even do it on the dl.
Everybody's gonna know you're gonna.
Be Out there scanning people with your
little Webcam.
No.
What if it snapped on the front?
So you're on the Webcam and starbucks
and what?
Starbucks.
It has to have a laptop at starbucks has
a thing that you had already has
attachments for like a card reader as
next week.
Be At starbucks.
We're going to be at the coffee.
No,
but that's what I'm saying.
It doesn't have a camera,
but yet it has an attachment that he
said,
well,
have accessories like microphones and
cameras and on the fucking thing,
bitch,
you want to be super special and wanted
to be the bomb.
I think they're trying to keep it down.
Price,
supply zone under $500 because here's
the thing.
If you're going to buy a book reader
right now,
you're on Amazon.com.
You're looking at the kindle,
the kindle,
that's $10 cheaper than this thing.
That makes a lot of sense actually,
and it's backlit.
I have a sony reader,
but it's.
I read in bed,
so when my girlfriend's sleeping I want
to read.
I can't.
I have to have a light on and it can't
even just be a dim light.
It has to be a bright light for me to
read it.
So now I got a little lip on soccer.
Get to sleep right next to you,
especially if you've got a kindle.
I love the cover.
He put the light here.
Bam.
You can read right next to him.
So this thing will be great for the
married dudes talking right next to me
when I was single.
I'd be like,
well,
I guess you can't sleep,
you know,
I can't sleep while you're reading a
book.
Well maybe the couch would be a better
place for you to sleep.
Totally.
What the fuck are you talking about?
So that's like $10 more.
What did you get that?
And if you didn't have one already,
if you are getting a book reader,
would you get $10 more?
Would you pay for the tablets?
That's the best argument I've ever
heard.
If I had to choose between the kindle
and the IPAD,
would for sure take the time.
And now the argument on the other side
yard man on the other side,
e ink,
uh,
is less stressful on the eyes.
But here's what I'm thinking.
Is that true?
It might be something to sell that
technology,
but.
And here's what I'm thinking.
I'm on the computer 11 hours a day,
10 hours a day.
I'm doing 99 percent reading and I've
never gone,
oh my foods once in a while.
Notice that I think,
well,
it could be also because I'm getting
older,
but my eyesight is not as good.
Meaning like say if I have to read a
vitamin bottle or it tells me how many
supposed to take.
I struggled with that Shit,
right?
No,
I have to try to focus.
It's not what it used to be,
so I don't read more than like an hour,
two hours.
I'm going to eat book anyways a day and
so I'm thinking if I'm on the computer
12 hours already a day,
now you use two hours of that.
I don't think it's caught.
Flaco says everything.
Apple makes us perfect.
Steve Jobs is God and Bill Gates is a
Nazi.
Was obviously no,
those are strong words.
Do you think that's the real flop on the
real flap or is a craziest?
If you don't only as well the craziest
characters on the Internet and he's just
nutty dude from England and let's get
fucked up all day and he's got a lot of
money so he doesn't have to work.
So the dude just gets online,
just trolls.
People in flux with them all day.
He's really hilarious.
He's crazy.
You can find at your website,
[inaudible] dot net on the forums and
slept for flap out and he just picks
fights with people.
He finds somebody just insults them over
and over again and everybody's
discussing assholes.
Guy's an asshole and yeah.
Yeah.
But there's something about it that's so
endearing is he's really doing it for
entertainment.
He's a character.
He's like an internet character that's
like running through this,
uh,
this show we're doing in the show is the
website,
the forums,
and he's like,
this character.
He's like,
one of the ideas is this insane won't
meet us,
either won't meet us.
He's kind of a shut in,
but I understand that,
you know,
I mean if you're some crazy dudes just
stays on the Internet all day.
I wouldn't even care what he looks like.
He could be totally trouble over this
whole story.
I don't care.
I just think he's an interesting dude.
Be Nice to say hi,
but he doesn't want us to take pictures
of it and put it online because then
everybody will have evidence.
They'll have weapons and ammunition to
go against him.
And his Internet wars and they're
supposedly one picture of him.
Yeah.
But who the fuck knows if not smiling
and he's never met anybody.
How do we know it can be a boyfriend.
Could be one of your ex.
It's vicious.
And who the hell knows?
We have no idea.
It's a guy.
No idea about the internet.
The fastest meeting people that are
cool.
I have so many friends.
You are one of them.
I met on the Internet,
but there's so many people that we've
met from your message board and in other
places.
That seems like a crazy thing to say.
It seems like you're an idiot.
What are you doing?
Fucking people from your message board,
but you know when you're either.
Bottom line is for real.
It's like you're meeting people all over
the country.
Anyone when you're doing standup,
what are the differences that make give
you meet them online first and wouldn't
that be smarter?
You know,
the only way to interact with people is.
I mean the Internet is the greatest for
that.
Like there's people that could never
have relationships that didn't have any
friends that are nothing going on in
their real life,
but they developed the whole Internet
worlds,
man,
quick player buddies of mine when I was
like,
seriously addicted to playing quake.
There's like lived their whole life on
the Internet and that's where all their
friendships came from.
And you get to know people like they're
in,
you know,
it's,
it's a little more,
it sounds crazy saying that you meet
people from the Internet,
but it's really probably pretty
intelligent.
Uh,
girls that like use dating sites.
They used to be thought of as losers,
you know,
you'd hear about like,
oh,
her sister,
she's on a fucking match.com
or wherever the fuck it is.
Like,
Oh,
poor girl,
what the fuck?
Then you think about being a chick.
Oh,
the fucking scumbags out there when you
want to like,
listen to them talk for awhile first,
see what they have,
what nutty shit they want to say in
their email.
See how they say you're in your.
Do you use that apostrophe?
You fucking Cretin you cave person.
You know,
you know what I mean?
It's funny.
That's that dating sites,
how many different ones?
They are like j date.
That's for Jewish people.
They have one for the people that just
have herpes.
I forget the name of it.
They have one for like anything you
could possibly want.
All girls is suck.
Magic Johnson
the folder.
That was funny.
I listen to this guy and this guy says,
Joe ever heard about reverse speech?
Everything you say says something in
reverse.
Now.
Ordinarily I would say that's retarded
bullshit,
but I smoked some marijuana right before
we did this broadcast and I'm like,
man,
who the hell knows?
Maybe.
Maybe we just don't know that in
language you can reverse it and it can
show true intention.
Is that possible by the way,
your intonations and.
No,
I mean I don't think it is,
but maybe it is.
What the fuck do I know?
Well,
you know,
things that are possible are so nutty.
You know?
Why?
Why do you think that?
I mean,
that could be just some weird side
effect or speech that when you reverse
things,
it says the opposite of what the person
or the person really means is possible.
Shit.
What the fuck knows?
The world is so nutty as it is.
The fact that we're on this sphere that
hovers around this gigantic nuclear
explosion.
It flies to the galaxy,
but everybody wants to talk about the
cast of Jersey shore renegotiating their
deal.
I mean that's like the number one
conversation and or how many,
you know,
how many more millions they're going to
give Conan O'brien at Fox or you know,
how many more checks that tiger woods
fuck [inaudible] his wife's going to get
back together with them.
It's like we get so caught up in
nonsense and I've been trying to figure
that out more and more as I get older,
like what it is,
because it's not just you.
I say,
you know people.
we,
I get caught up in that stupid shit too.
I was wondering what was going to happen
to John when he left kate because he
wasn't making any money anymore and all
of a sudden he has to pay Matt Alimony,
you know,
because I think they're probably
negotiate that shit when he was on the
show and he's making good money,
but they kicked them off that show and
then they're going to sue him and he was
the poor dude,
you know?
I mean he just fell apart in front of
the whole world.
First he fell apart in front of the
whole world because he was married to
that chick who was just treating him
like shit.
Like it would.
You would watch that show and like,
wow,
that bitch is harsh,
but then you realize,
God damn.
Could you imagine having eight kids with
that week?
Dude,
that guy such a bitch that you would be
like,
oh,
I can't count on this motherfucker.
Come on,
get up.
You have to work.
Come on.
We were just lazy and soft and dol
minded,
but he got on TV and when he got on tv,
I think girls just start saying,
you shouldn't take that from him.
She's a bitch.
She doesn't appreciate you.
I see on that show.
Thank you so high.
I think you're so cool.
Next thing you know he's in there.
Oh Shit.
I'm hot and cool.
He didn't realize that he himself had
been tricked by fame.
It's just like those poor girls that
fuck them.
That's how powerful famous fame tricks.
Even the person that has the fame.
The worst is that Tila?
Tequila girl.
Oh,
she's the worst.
Every time I hear about I just get sick
to my stomach.
I'm just waiting for a baby right now.
Listen,
that's all.
Just to get you to pay attention.
She's crafty.
Little little winch.
Yeah.
She's going to do a porn I would
imagine.
I think she already has.
I remember having.
It's amazing when they like.
Just totally.
I'm like,
orchestrate sex tapes,
you know?
Is there any doubt that the Kim
Kardashians sex tape.
Have you ever watched a I?
Yeah.
You.
There's different cameras.
Yeah,
I mean time.
Is it really different?
There's different angles that I knew it
was tentative.
I thought that the company does
and she keeps her bra,
which is very disturbing.
Some Tutsis free.
Then mtds free like,
oh,
come on.
Just let 'em free.
She probably doesn't like her nipples.
She looks like she's probably got some
big ones.
What do you think?
You got to guess?
Oh,
definitely be picture one punch.
Can pictures of her nipples.
Other something.
Watch your whole video.
I watched a few seconds skip right time
to beat off and have a very hard time
beating off to black guys.
Fucking white girls because I don't feel
like that's me.
I don't know how much fantasy can I have
to what?
To me,
it just bleed off in front of my new
kitten for the first time today,
today and how much in front of them?
How far was I was beating off and the
cat jumped right up on my laptop and I'm
like,
oh,
well I guess you're going to see it
eventually.
So there it is.
Like it feel like you.
It's like I really hope like my
grandparents are like,
you find out later that you're like,
you're your,
your,
your ancestors come back as like animals
or something that they can watch you
like to talk to build that bridge.
Yeah.
Talk.
Remember Joe,
his joke about chuck it off for the cat
is about to come and the kids doing this
move.
Move.
Oh,
it's weird how like a cats used to be
worshiped back in the day.
Yeah.
What do you think?
That's.
I mean what if there is something to a
cat that we just don't know and it was
lost in transition,
you know,
like no one ever wrote it down.
Like,
oh by the way,
if you look at the cat's eyes every day
at midnight,
you can talk to we know what just
about like Egypt worshiping cats.
It's like they were so good at making
things like how I wonder what they were
really like because we don't really have
any idea about their cultural.
Translating their language over the
English.
It's also tricky and the hieroglyphs and
they don't really know how far back
there their history goes because there's
like John Anthony West,
that guy thinks that their history goes
back like 30,000
years and he even has hieroglyphs that
prove it,
but they were so smart when it came to
constructing things.
I wonder what they would like,
you know,
socially,
you know.
Yeah.
Like,
like,
just sitting around talking to them,
you know,
it's really kind of crazy when you think
about what those,
those people pulled off.
And that was like supposedly a 22,000,
500 years before Christ before zero.
That's incredible.
And they were working with seven cats,
like maybe they,
maybe they know.
Yeah,
there's something with fucking smart
where they,
I mean I would like to know how smart
they were.
Maybe they were just completely retarded
and just didn't really know how to build
things and they will just write and
that's why they're there.
Culture to suck.
But I don't think so because people
like,
um,
I think socrates and no Hurghada this
Hurghada just went over from um,
no,
there's the,
there's the uh,
there's the charge for this cat is very
emotional.
Sometimes can manage.
She would get mad because we've got
another cat to.
She started peeing on Shit.
Speaking of the other cat just walks in.
Right.
And you said that Oliver,
come here buddy.
All of this cool.
I liked him.
He's a cool little dude.
I like cats.
You know,
when I like cats because I'm not
starving to death.
That's why I don't understand like when
you people are living in Egypt,
I mean how fucking smart were they?
They must've had a pretty sophisticated
culture because they were really into
keep animals as pets and feeding.
The dogs are going to protect your
house.
They're gonna do the campaigns doing
shit.
You rubbed them.
That's all you get.
You get ipr and I like,
you're robbing me.
That's all it is.
So they were smart enough to build
pyramids,
but yet they worshiped cats because
there's.
There's something to the captain we
don't know about spazz.
Is there something to cats?
You ever see a cat when the light hits
their eyes in a certain way and it looks
like a Hologram or something going on in
their eyes.
That shit's weird.
Well,
their eyesight is insane there.
I started some insane amount better than
ours.
Is it?
Oh yeah.
Their eyesight is incredible and it's
dark and darkens vision is incredible
and their hearing is incredible.
That cat hears everything.
She'll hear shit like that.
Her.
She'll be sleeping and then you'll see
her all curled up and then I'll move
something in the room.
You see her little ears just go.
You know,
it's like they're,
they're tuning in to like specific
locations where mice are trying to sneak
by,
you know,
that they got this killer.
Fuck it.
It's really weird to see because the
bottom line is she only respects me and
loves me and everything first of all
because I feed her and pet her,
but also because I'm so much bigger than
in her because if that was smaller than
her,
she would fuck me up.
Cats don't give a fuck about little
things.
You can't keep a pet journal around your
cat.
They don't have that agreement.
You can train a dog to not kill a
durable.
You cannot train a cat.
No,
you can't do it.
You leave that job around that cat is
gonna.
Fuck that thing up.
It's crazy.
They cannot avoid it.
They love it.
They love killing things,
man.
Yeah,
I was.
When I was growing up,
when I was a kid,
we had a big ass black tomcat and he
used to kill and he used to kill
squirrels.
We lived right across the street from
this river and there was like,
oh,
a whole.
A lot of wooded areas.
Like many,
many acres.
As soon as a lot of animals around there
and these fucking girls would be all
over this tree and this cat,
which is creep through the grass,
he's a fucking monster.
One pause and hover and I would watch
him from the window across the street
from our house dude who said it was like
National Geographic.
He fucking chases him and that squirrels
trying to leave and he pounds on their
back and get the back and sink their
teeth into the neck and dragged this
thing in between his legs.
That was what was really crazy.
He had this girl's body,
which was almost as big as him.
It was pretty fucking big,
like half the size of his body and he's
dragging it in between his legs and
taking this girl across the street to
our house.
I was like
nutty as APP.
What if I went out and killed a dog?
What if I went out and killed a dog with
a knife in front of you?
Wouldn't you like look at me different?
Would it be like,
Bro,
what the fuck did you.
But you know,
he came in.
I'm like,
what's up?
I'm like rubbing his head.
What's up?
Little Buddy.
When you gotta sell you gotta you gotTa
score.
But I didn't.
I didn't feel bad.
He murdered this poor little animal
because his girl,
probably a little squirrel family was
scrub mother.
He's not even hungry.
I feed his fat ass everyday.
He would come and I'd give him a fucking
Kenneth Dog,
cat,
little cat food.
He would be fine.
Maybe that square was trying to help you
to like ricky ticky.
Timbo remember that old,
that old story where he's trying to save
the family from the snake.
Maybe the square was trying to think.
Squirrels.
Little animals I liked,
but I'm a.
I discriminate when it comes to rodents,
like squirrels,
they make the grade.
I never feel bad when I see them,
but if I see a rat that's close,
you know,
Iran is that close.
Like say if you're sitting with your kid
at the park and there's a tree and the
tree is literally right there and the
trees go scrub.
Like,
oh look at this girl and this girl.
He's right there.
But if that was a rat,
like,
oh,
get the fuck back.
The rats,
they're so rad.
Fucking stick gonna wrap it up.
You just start freaking out and yelling.
Shit the fuck out of here.
Fucking rat.
But I'm scared of rats,
dude.
That's what that big.
And I'm scared of him in Jersey.
Devil come at,
you know you've got to be careful.
Like don't bite your ass man.
I got a came after by a skunk last week
and they charged me and the dog and
Chris,
my dogs.
It's like kill,
kill,
kill.
Well listen to me but doesn't know it's
going to spray him.
And then that's going to be like five
hours of my time of trying to use
vinegar and imagine to a dog.
Dogs have these insane.
They like it or not.
Oh my God.
Of course you don't like it would be
funny if they did,
would.
That would be like an animal that's
trying to commit suicide.
You know,
if that was the evolutionary thing with
met the dogs loved it and you spray your
shit.
The dog liked it.
Did want you to spray so they'd want to
kill you all the time.
Psychiatric catnip.
Why does catnip not working on any other
animal?
No,
these guys are weird.
Look at this guy.
Joe,
what's your favorite way to smoke?
Like some people get nutty about it.
Just smoke your weed.
People did because there's a certain
group of people that follow you that are
so burned out that they just like,
you know,
maybe he's young to the game.
Well there's a lot of young health was
the vaporizer is certainly your best
bet.
Bonds are nice.
I like a bond,
right?
Glass.
Anything.
Brian doesn't give a fuck.
It goes right to the Dick joints,
joints because you only have to light at
once.
No,
but really if you want to do it the
healthiest way of vaporizers,
way to go and don't think that eating
and it's just as healthy.
People think that eating pot is just as
healthy.
It is.
I mean it's not going to kill you,
but it will freak you out.
And one of the reasons why it freaks you
out because it produces this thing
called 11 hydroxy.
It's a metabolite that your liver
produces when you eat marijuana and
apparently it's not psychoactive when
you smoke it,
like it's so you don't get the same
effect,
but when you eat marijuana it becomes
like four times more psychoactive than
if you smoke it.
So if you have like a lot of weed and
you make brownies with them,
that's the problem with these things.
You,
you eat a Brownie and you're like,
what the fuck are.
You can't believe how much weed is in
it.
You have to sit down and it's because as
it's going through your system,
it's creating this 11 hydroxy
metabolite,
which I like.
And one of the reasons why I like it is
because it's,
it makes me very self critical.
It makes me examine all sorts of things
about myself.
Like there's anything about myself that
I don't like.
If I'm being lazy,
if I'm being a douchebag,
if I'm being short with people,
if I'm not,
you know,
if I'm not focused on what I really
should be focused on in my life,
anything that might be bugging me,
my subconscious mind.
This 11 hydroxy makes you think about it
like in depth and they can really freak
people out if you've got some shit that
you're pushing in the back of your head.
You know?
It's like what people call.
I was paranoid.
I think what paranoia is is people that
when you get high on marijuana,
I think we're paranoid is people who
just are there,
they're getting too much information for
them to manage and they haven't done
such a good job of managing their
consciousness in the first place and so
when this stuff is hitting them,
what's happening is they're just.
It's overload and they can't control it
and they freak out and they say,
I can't smoke weed.
It gets me paranoid,
but I think it's more indicative of this
year.
You don't really know how you feel about
yourself.
life.
You're.
You're looking at life through barriers
because you're trying to not see
everything because you're trying to
focus on one particular thing with your
life or try and get your shit together
and you don't realize how many things
about your life really are freaking you
out and bothering you until you smoke.
Pot and pot just makes you examine them.
You know,
we as,
as,
as people,
we like to avoid shit that bugs us.
And so I like when people like overeat
to get over some childhood molestation.
They don't even fucking realize what
they're doing.
They're just distracting themselves with
something else.
You know?
I think.
I think we do shit like that all the
time.
Anything I kind of lost in near halfway.
Listen,
be careful with your weed.
That's all I'm.
I'm being paranoid is a good thing.
It's for real.
It is.
I mean,
the experience of being paranoid.
When you smoke weed,
it's to get you to look at yourself.
It's to get you to look at life.
It's,
you're not,
you're not.
You're not looking at it all as clearly
as you could and those jolts of
perception.
You misinterpret as paranoia like what
you're doing is just dealing with the
information that's already been there.
Just the fact that you're this fleshy,
temporary,
soft,
mushy creature that is literally
connected with nothing above your head
except gases and air and then fucking
space and above that there's asteroids
and planets and fucking giant nuclear
explosions and sons and it's all right
there and you're just this thing that
doesn't exactly know what it's doing is
kind of going along with the flow of
everybody else and sit in traffic like
everybody else hoping that someone of us
is like guiding this thing,
but they're not the ones guiding shit,
and that is if you're not thinking about
that,
if you don't,
you have an address that as a human
being and you start eating fucking pot
brownies,
that shit will pull up you over the
head.
You'll freak out,
you'll,
you'll be scared.
You'll,
you'll curl into a fetal position.
You know like what?
What life really is is frightening to
people and marijuana will expose the
fuck out of that.
Expose what it really is.
You know,
this is not a goddamn moving.
That's the problem we are living life
like it is a movie because we're
fucking.
We really are programmed by culture.
I think.
I mean,
I love movies.
Don't get me wrong.
I love cds.
I love songs I love.
I love all forms of expression,
all entertaining forms of expression
except dance,
dance,
like a,
like musicals.
That doesn't mean shit to me.
I see choreographed dancing like,
oh,
you're moving together.
You know,
you don't like a musical movies at all.
Or South Park's uh,
yeah.
That was beautiful.
Beautiful.
Musical was beautiful.
I need to make a new south park movie.
What the fuck?
It's accept.
Canadians must have been very first,
right?
They're always right now.
Have you seen that?
That ginger video knows that when people
are beaten up,
know this kid.
He's a redhead and I thought,
man,
this kid is a redheaded.
Has come from.
Where did you park?
That's crazy.
That's sad because there's an episode
where like gingers were like some,
some kid was like right there.
South Park was like head a ginger day.
You're hitting them all day.
They're mimicking sapper.
What?
I mean,
that's nothing new when you're in high
school.
She used to beat the fuck out.
So that video is this,
this redheaded guy that gives like a
speech for four minutes and it's kind of
like leave Brittany alone style and it's
just,
it's you don't want your brings up God
and religion through it and stuff and it
just sit there like terrified of this
guy.
Not Bad for him.
I was just terrified.
And you got to watch it and maybe we'll
set up for break or something.
He's fucking up the whole cause.
Yeah.
For other redheads,
redheads and one love crazy bitch.
That's the problem is by the time you
know,
you're,
you're out there looking for love.
You're probably so God damn damaged.
Yes.
Most of us are fucking damaged.
Right?
I mean if you had to,
if you had to guess like what amount of
people are still working on issues from
a childhood?
It's 100.
Yeah.
Timing really damaged.
It's just,
that's what happens,
you know?
Well,
it's also you have to reprogram the way
you look at the world.
You know,
you look at the world a certain way
because you think,
you know,
that's how you were taught by your
parents and you know when you're like in
your teen years,
you start having to restructure things.
Your teen years,
you start looking at things like they
don't even know what the fuck they're
talking about.
They're talking crazy shit and you
realize God damn it.
My parents are just some fucking people.
Just like all the other idiots.
I mean all day they just fucked.
Let's see.
There are no different than my idiot
friends.
They're no different than my idiot
teachers.
They just fucked,
they fucked and they made me and sell
shit.
And so when those teenage years,
when you're trying to like reformulate
the view,
that's when it starts and it continues
through your whole life,
you know?
Do you think that you would be the same
dude though?
If you had like A.
Oh,
I don't want to watch that stuff sold.
Do you think you would be the same dude
if you had a perfect childhood?
No,
I think it's just like that
you're a whole theory about like you
are.
How you lived,
you know,
everyone starts off at the same person
pretty much and just every single little
thing you've got to believe that,
you know,
it's like if you wrote down the hill,
you're going to in a mud,
you're going to look different than
yeah,
person next to you.
Yeah.
That's why people really have to have
compassion because,
you know,
if you,
if we really are all the same thing,
this is my theory,
if you haven't heard it before.
And I had this when I was eight some pot
and it was on a boat in Hawaii and uh,
I was um,
on this boat and we were,
we were fishing and there was dolphins
that were next to the book.
The dolphins were playing with us.
They would get by the boat and they
would jump up in the air and we would
go,
whoa.
And every time they jump up there and we
go,
what's up,
what's up top?
And when we would do that,
they would get excited.
And so they were like showing off.
They were like communicating with us.
I was like,
God damn,
there's so conscious.
And I started thinking about it like
they're responding to us.
I'm like,
I wonder what life must be like,
what consciousness wants to be like for
the Dolphin.
And I wonder if it's similar to humans
and I wonder if it's the same.
I was thinking,
I wonder if they have the exact same
consciousness.
It's just filtered through an entirely
different environment.
It totally different skin.
You know,
you're in a fish's body and a totally
different way of communicating and
totally different language that's almost
indecipherable.
But what if it's exactly the same thing,
the inside the consciousness.
And then I thought about it,
I'm like,
oh my God.
Like what if that's the case with
people?
What if we are all exactly the same
thing?
We just are transmitted through
different biological filters,
different life experiences,
different childhoods,
different everything,
different bad genetic rolls of the dice.
I mean people are born with different
ailments and diseases and people are
born crippled.
You know what,
what?
The reason why I supposed to have
compassionate is that easily could have
been you.
It's,
it's just a like a filter that the
consciousness is going through.
But the consciousness is one thing,
it's all the same.
You are just like me.
It's just like any of your uniqueness
has to do with your biology and your
interpretations of your experiences as
you're growing up.
You know,
your unique personality,
your unique personality that everybody
talks about when were a child could
easily be attributed to what kind of
machine you're running.
You know,
only take something.
Everybody's biology is different.
You know that if you watch porn,
right?
There's people that we're blessed with
gigantic decks and there's poor dudes
with little tiny decks and there's girls
with incredible bodies and there's other
girls that like whatever,
no matter what they do,
they can't lose that last 20 pounds.
That's just fact that that is what it is
you're born with.
There's variables like this variables
with oranges,
you'll see one orange as big and another
one that's not so big.
They're not all the same and these
various chemicals and then on top of
these various chemicals that are all in
balance,
all these different hormones.
When a top of that,
then it's like,
how does this particular model interact
with its environment,
your own unique experiences?
I mean,
how many times have you seen something
that your friends didn't and it fucked
you up for the rest of the day.
You know,
you know,
like you see somebody get hit by a car,
you see something and then you have the
same friends.
You go to the same and all of a sudden
you don't want to hang out with them
anymore.
You think that things are frivolous.
You think they're being retarded.
You know,
you hear about a girl getting raped and
you're the one who freaks out and it's
what you see one thing and it will set
you off in a certain direction and it's
like,
so who the fuck knows what your
personality is?
You know who the fuck knows how much of
it is your body?
How much of it is your experiences?
How much of it is what you learned from
your parents and how much of theirs is
the same shit?
How much of your personalities is really
just you reacting and saying what you
have to say and doing what you have to
do to get by in your environment,
but at the core of everybody from
fucking serial killers to to the most
compassionate people on Earth,
it's very likely that the consciousness
is the same male,
female.
That's all biological.
It's very logical that the thinking.
It's very possible that the,
the root of it all.
When you think about yourself as you,
that it's all the same.
That's nuts.
Somehow cats involved with that shit.
Some shit.
And it's really interesting because then
when there's like personality test on
websites,
like there's dating websites we're
talking about.
So like there's,
you take personality tests so you're all
trying to take a test that's based on
what,
you know the person,
you know,
like,
how did they know it's personal
interests or stupid as fuck.
I just like same people that have
glitter tags on their mind space,
you know,
what are you taking it?
You don't know what you're fucking
personalities like once you go sit down
in the grass by yourself.
And think about shit,
you know,
take a goddamn meditation class at a
certain point in time as a human being
human being to become responsible for
your own biology,
you know,
and that's what we don't teach people
well,
we need to teach kids in school.
There needs to be,
you know,
you have math and you have English and
these are all very important subjects,
but we also need is how to manage your
mind,
how to think,
how to think correctly,
how to,
when something comes up in your life,
how to deal with it and turn it into
something,
to your advantage.
How not to go into a negative spiral and
have your whole fucking life fall apart
because of one thing and that that's.
These are very important that people
learn how to think,
how to control your mind.
You know,
and how many people actually do that.
It's not that many,
right?
I mean there's not that many people
really know how to think.
You know,
how to think positively,
how to effect the people around you as
positively as you can.
How to move your life into the way you
move your life into a healthy place.
Very hard to do.
It's because we're all starting from
scratch.
You know,
we're all starting from scratch where
I'll try to read books.
We were never taught that shit in
school.
They'd be,
if they really want to teach you how to
be a good employee,
how to,
you know,
make a good living.
That's you being a better person.
Being better at being a person,
being better at managing your life is
very important.
They should be teaching kids how to
think correctly,
like early in school and they should
have discipline and I don't mean
discipline by like,
you know,
do what everybody tells you to do.
That's not discipline with discipline
is,
is you have to do a certain amount.
You have to do something like do
anything.
Anything that's really hard,
like whether it's swimming or archery or
playing chess or you know,
doing Jujitsu for kids,
having something that's difficult to do
is very important.
They need to be pushed.
You know,
it's very,
very important.
You could develop so much more of who
you are if you've already pushed your
boundaries.
If you're been lazy,
your whole life is so hard to get out of
not being lazy anymore,
and this is all shit that they should be
teaching in school,
man.
It should totally be teaching that shit
in school,
you know,
and it's not just history.
You know,
when I was a kid,
they fucking taught us.
Columbus discovered America,
you know,
that was still being taught and now we
know for a fact he didn't it.
I think it still is,
isn't it?
I don't think so.
Really.
I mean he's,
he's still,
we celebrate Columbus Day,
but I think now they say he landed in
the West indies.
That's what your question was.
Was the gentlemen,
are we serious about our dolphin stuff?
Yeah,
man.
Dolphins rape other dolphins.
Oh,
I know they do.
They do.
They rape other dolphins.
They eat dolphin babies.
It's that,
you know,
infanticide and dolphins.
I think that's what it's called is what
they do is the female dolphins try to
fuck as many male dolphins as they can
because if they run across a male
dolphin that they haven't fucked and
they have babies,
the male might kill the babies to get
the female to breed because the females
won't breed while they're taking care of
the young,
so they have to fuck as many male
dolphins as they can so that when they
do come across a male dolphin and he's,
he sees him with the baby.
If she fucked him,
he won't kill the babies because he
doesn't know if they're his.
It's crazy humans,
you know,
rape and kill babies too.
Yeah.
I mean we don't do it in such large
numbers as dolphins though I dolphins do
it,
like kind of like as a matter of,
you know,
they're more board they're need in the
water on.
They're like,
but we don't have.
I think it's that the board.
I think it's that they can affect their
environment.
We see evolution in dolphins and it's in
a very strange scale.
It's very much different than ours.
It's like they're,
they're super intelligent and cognitive,
you know,
they,
they have these amazing abilities to
communicate,
but yet they can't move anything with
their hands.
They don't create anything.
So they're out in the wild.
So their,
their world is just way harsher.
They're basically,
dolphins are like the fucking blue
people in Avatar,
you know,
the blue people and advertiser like
super intelligent,
but they're,
these motherfuckers live in the jungle.
You got to be hard,
you know,
like some soft dude behind a computer
keyboard,
you know,
you've got to be like that crazy.
But shooting arrows at those crazy black
dog things,
you know.
And that's.
The dolphins are like,
man,
they're in the fucking woods there in
the ocean.
But that's,
there's sharks out there.
And men show killer whales eat dolphins
all the time.
They're cousins.
Madison's your cousin eight.
You killer whales will fuck up some
dolphins.
They fuck up sharks to kill the whales
of the pimps have the ocean.
They're just running shit.
You know,
they don't take shit from nobody.
the only people they do is people.
That's the only thing that they take
shit from because people,
this is a,
a store that I read on the Internet and
this I would like to add,
ask you twitter people and people are
watching on ustream.
I wonder if um,
if it's,
if it's possible that this is a true
story.
What I heard was that the orcas or
killer whales used to attack people and
been attacking people for a long time.
But then after World War Two they
stopped.
And one of the reasons why it's this
American soldiers were apparently I'm
targeting killer whales in the ocean for
practice.
You know,
that's how they would work on their.
They're shooting out of the planes and
they would drop bombs on them and shit.
The whales just completely stopped
eating people.
I mean,
that doesn't,
that seems like something somebody made
up,
right?
Doesn't it?
But what if it wasn't.
That would be pretty fucking crazy,
you know,
because I know culture is,
do have like images,
like old eskimo images,
just like a killer whale attacking
people.
Like really ancient stuff.
I wonder.
A hippie.
Interesting.
And they knew what was up.
You know,
if like other goal of these
motherfuckers can fly now and trap
shifts when was okay,
we're good.
We're done.
Just we tap.
Imagine if they eat everything else,
why would they eat?
People?
They save people all the time.
Like that's really nutty when you're
talking about an animal that's that
intelligent,
like murders,
Dolphin.
When people fall in the ocean,
killer whales have been known and many
times to nudge people towards boats and
help them.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Same as dolphins.
Then none of them fuck with people
because we have the ability to change
our environment.
They're just as ruthless just as smart,
but they're fucked with their bodies.
A little fucking flippers and shit the
fuck you up if you're in their world,
but that's what you need to get by in
their world.
Our world requires much more finer
moves,
you know,
and our ability to manipulate shit.
Like had things gone just a little bit
different in evolution.
If you believe in evolution,
you know the dolphins and easily they
can easily be and shit the killer whales
and dolphins.
Imagine if there was something like that
with us,
if those were all the same intelligence,
imagine there's something like that with
us,
like some giant trolls that were just as
smart as us and would come in and kill
people.
Show up at your village and start eating
us.
Jack in us.
Well,
there is happening.
That's us and monkeys.
Beowulf.
Well,
that's us in monkeys.
If you look at like African countries
Bushmeat,
you see the cell chimpanzee hands his
ass trays and shit.
They just go into the forest and fuck
those things up and eat them.
You know?
That's pretty crazy when you think,
God,
what other?
Something like that with us.
That could happen,
man.
Nothing can happen.
Well,
we didn't like.
Can you fucking imagine?
I mean there is.
There are predators,
humans if you're around them,
but you know,
for the most part they're not
intelligent.
These fucking things are intelligent
killer whales or just the smartest.
Often their genius.
They're like the smartest human
supposedly.
Well,
if that's the case,
man,
you imagine subject as smart as people,
but giant and likes to eat us.
Robots.
No,
it's going to be.
We're going to go,
we're going to build our enemy,
our Predator,
we're going to build our predator.
Some some new months are going to come
from the sky.
We would never be able to get to this
point.
The reason why we've got to this point
culture or with technology and with our
inventions and all the shit,
the reason why it's because no one's
been eating us.
We've had all this downtime with all
this downtime to come up with things
because otherwise we would've never
gotten to this point.
He never be comfortable enough to sit
around,
crunching algorithms,
trying to figure out how to make a
pentium processor.
You would never get to that point.
You'd be constantly running from the
giant troll people that want to eat your
asshole.
You know,
they were just kill people and the way
chimps eat monkeys.
You ever watched the which Mc?
Hammer parties and while they're alive
they don't tell them.
That's a weird thing about predators
seem to kill people and then eat them
like big cats.
You know,
like,
you know,
animals that like kill things for a
living.
You know,
like big cats,
big cats,
they only eat grass so they can throw
up.
That's all they do.
And these,
uh,
these animals,
when they,
when they catch something,
it's very important that they kill it.
So they just grabbed him by the neck.
And Jack,
I'm immediately.
But like,
chimps don't do that.
Chimps eat berries,
they eat all kinds of shit.
They're omnivores.
They can eat meat or vegetables and
fruits.
So when they kill monkeys,
which is like their favorite shit to do,
they love monkeys,
they love to eat them.
And they have all these elaborate traps
where they,
uh,
there's,
you can see them online,
will,
will find you the youtube clip.
I'll find it right now because it's
pretty fucking trippy.
It's a youtube.
I'm just going to youtube chimps,
eat monkeys and a,
my point is they,
they eat them alive,
man.
They eat them alive,
they rip them apart,
they don't kill him.
First it,
same thing with bears.
Bears ever see like a bear when it,
uh,
like that's the thing about that Timothy
Treadwell.
Dude,
that dude from grizzly man,
the fucking video or the is there's a
cap on the video when the bear ate them,
but the audio is there in the audience.
Seven minutes long,
seven minutes long.
Is that not leaked yet?
Seven minute.
Because the the woman who was his
girlfriend didn't want it to leak.
If you don't,
if you haven't seen grizzly man,
you must.
You must.
Secrets who?
Matt is one of the most genius fucking
movies ever and it's like a subtle
comedy.
It's,
I mean it's so hard to describe.
This guy was so insane and he was living
with bears and the way it's edited
together and Werner Herzog is typically
not known for making funny movies.
Right?
He's like a serious director.
I don't think he meant to make this fun,
but this guy is so ridiculous.
He's have like a bear.
Come here,
come here.
He's gay.
Or then Ricky Martin in a room full of
dicks.
He's,
he's says this guy is so gay and he's
out there in the woods with a camera
going,
if I was gay I could just meet a girl
and we could just.
Or can you meet a guy and a restroom?
We can just hook up that I'm not gay.
So what do I do?
Want to bring it up.
It wouldn't do it in specific.
I just go to a restaurant,
right?
Like,
why is a great movie?
I need to refinance tastic movie grizzly
man,
you have to see it.
But this guy was like really into saving
the grizzly bears.
So he's up there in Alaska and he's
like,
you know,
the fucking park rangers now he's
motherfuckers out here saving him
everyday and the bears are looking like,
who is this crazy bitch?
Like they weren't anything.
It was letting people know the bears
were there,
but they knew bears were there.
Like he wasn't saving them.
They're at a national park,
you know,
occasionally there's a poaching,
but that's going to happen everywhere.
They're not going to not poach because
you're there.
Stupid,
you know.
Okay.
Here,
chimps killing and eating a monkey.
I'm going to take this.
Yeah,
this is the one.
It's ruthless.
Ooh.
I'll take this link and I'll throw it up
on twitter right now from a peoples when
I'm really high.
I can't type that good if I think about
it.
Uh,
let me
into the zoo.
The Los Angeles Zoo.
Yeah.
I don't like to go to the zoo after the
last time I went,
I wrote that piece about the zoo animal
prison on,
in the blog.
But I realized because I was super baked
and when,
uh,
you know,
like when I,
like we were talking about earlier when
you super bait dealing much more
sensitive than I was watching these
animals.
I'm like,
this is a horrendous life.
Just because they can move doesn't mean
they're alive.
They don't allow the predators to kill
and eat.
That's like the,
the,
they take you away and eat,
you know,
you can't talk to people ever again.
You know,
you just,
you get locked up in a room by yourself
and,
and something else other than you has to
stare at you.
Right.
And you don't even get a,
you don't get to,
you know,
the one pleasure that animals that are
predators get.
I mean the reason why they go after the,
the kill,
it must be orgasmic.
I mean it's what they need to stay alive
and they're doing it with their mouth
and they're feeling the life leave the
animal.
And I mean it's,
it's imperative for them to be really
awesome at killing things in,
for them to survive.
So what must that feel like to them?
It must be incredible when it feels good
for us to fuck.
And there's so many of us.
It's like,
it's not even important that we fuck,
you know what I'm saying?
But it's your body is so programmed by
all the years of evolution to think that
it's very,
very important to make new human being.
So you get this fantastic reward when
you fuck.
It just feels so good.
And what it really is,
it's just nature trying to trick you
nature,
making sure that you're rewarded for
doing what you have to do to stay alive
and to continue to race well with a
Jaguar every day.
You have to kill some shit.
The fucking,
the physical rush,
the sensation of chasing something down
as it's running through the forest.
Not sure if you're going to get it and
sometimes they get away and Bam,
you got that motherfucker right by the
neck.
He feel a heartbeat and it's legs are
kicking and just put that little
antelope down.
That must be fantastic.
It must be fantastic and you don't even
give him that.
You just put them in this cage and you
slide cold meat in a tray and he eats it
and she was like,
what the fuck?
What the fuck did I do to deserve this
mean?
If you've got to keep them around,
I could see the argument much more to
kill all the predators than I could to
keep any of them around in cages,
you know,
because I could see what you're saying.
Listen,
we're going to get some video of all
these animals that can eat us.
We'll get some nice video,
documented a bunch of different formats
and peg mov put an iphone and then we're
going to kill them.
We're going to kill all of them.
Anything that kills us,
but why not?
What if they were to do it?
Like they had a huge open crazy space
and they made it kind of like fun and
everything that they would want,
but then they would like throw on like,
all right,
here's a cow onto the situation.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know.
I don't think you want them.
The problem is people don't want to see
that shit.
How about in the day?
I mean,
if you're going to do instead,
if you really want to teach children,
why is it okay?
It's kind of funny because why is it
okay to watch something like that on the
National Geographic show on discovery
channel?
They show you all the time.
Have you ever seen relentless enemies?
Uh,
maybe.
I'm pretty sure it's called relentless
enemies.
It's a fucking amazing documentary about
these lions in Africa that are.
They look like cartoon lines.
There are a lot like,
like,
like giant Mike Tyson lines that it's so
ridiculous and the females are bigger
than normal African male lions or as
big,
if not bigger than normal African male
lines,
which is an unprecedented mean.
It never exists.
These fucking lions are gigantic and the
reason why they're gigantic is because
they the river where they live changed
course about a hundred years ago and
all.
I may not even be 100,
it might have been more recent than now.
I have to look it up,
but they got stuck on this one island
with water buffalo only water buffalo.
So in order to survive,
they had an only killed the toughest
thing to kill.
So these giant fucking water buffaloes
are dangerous as fuck.
They're super powerful.
They've got these giant horns and
they'll come at you and stomp your ass
and they get broken legs and they can't
hunt again and then the fucking they
starve to death.
So it's a fucking dangerous proposition.
Will these ants,
these,
these tigers got gigantic because of it.
They got fucking huge and it's really
fascinating,
man.
Really fascinating to watch them try to
figure out how they're going to take out
these water buffalo and they're just so
much bigger than regular lions.
It's like,
it's crazy to watch man.
Really,
really intense documentary.
You're a huge documentary.
You'd like how many documentaries a talk
to you?
A lot of them.
Yeah.
Is it because you're just like science?
Have you always liked science?
I,
I do.
I just get fascinated by shit man.
You know what I mean?
Just the fact that that exists.
I mean if you,
how many people have their new approach,
but a lot of you guys knew about those
lines in Africa,
but you know,
he talked to her because you're on the
Internet and Shit and you're savvy
enough to be on the youth stream.
But like how many fucking people really
you know,
know,
know anything about the animal world or
space or you know,
mean you start seeing things about like
hyper Novas they blow up like
everything,
like within,
you know,
100 million fucking light years and
everything gets cooked and they happen
all the time throughout the galaxy.
And you're like,
what?
Like what is this?
They talk about how they can.
If one happened like anywhere near us,
we'd be cooked instantly.
Like it just blows everything apart all
around it.
Like this insane event where these
spirals of energy blast out from the
sides and it's been,
it's fucking nuts and it happens like
hundreds a day all over the universe.
Tuesday it's like,
to not be into documentaries to me seems
way crazier than to be into them.
There's so much nerdy shit going on out
there and no one cares.
You know the new season of losses,
right?
About the stock.
Oh yeah.
I read.
I can't wait for that though.
Every time I see that commercial,
I'm just like,
Oh God.
There was one second avenue.
The documentary on the Lions folks.
I think it's called relentless enemies.
Let me,
let me check right now.
What is that thing you?
You're saying you have to smoke
cigarettes.
Oh No,
no.
I'm Jonesing for last.
Oh,
but did you know,
did you hear somebody hit by a.
They want.
This is how dumb somebody whites went to
go get the nicotine patches and they
wanted to quit smoking faster.
So they put every single one of the
nicotine patches on their body that you
know,
you get a box of them and they thought
that if they put more patches on their
body,
so suck.
And here's,
here's,
I can show you this right here.
It's called relentless enemies is the
the documentary on the and now here,
this is how bad people suck.
This fucking guy,
Dr Levin Cac more film Guy,
Amazon Dot Com.
Amazon.com.
He says,
how can someone mess up such a great
documentary film in such a way?
I hope National Geographic does
something about it and we can buy it
again.
I tried a of different age.
DVD.
Oh,
okay.
He's saying,
okay,
this guy is saying to exit the.
No,
he's saying that the DVD he got it was
any of the other ones over there,
but yeah,
it's fucking nuts.
Fucking amazing.
It's amazing.
Oh,
it's saying we will not play on the
video.
The problem with digital media is pretty
huge right now.
Somebody bashing itunes the other day
saying that it doesn't play.
Wow.
For two or three are saying these three
reviews that are on the front page
anyway,
the documentary itself,
if these poor guys could get the DVD to
work,
it's fucking incredible.
I mean,
it just shows you how quickly life can
adapt.
You know,
there's these,
uh,
you know,
the Amazon rain forest has only existed.
None of the Amazon.
It rather.
The Congo has only existed in that form
for like a few thousand years and
thousands of years before that it was
like grasslands.
So there's animals that are trapped
inside the Congo that are animals that
live on the grass plains,
like rhinos are trapped in there and
deer and antelope.
And there's one little antelope that has
developed the ability to swim underwater
because the Congo was filled with water,
develop the ability to swim underwater
up to a hundred yards and it eats fish
and it's a fucking antelope.
And it's,
yeah,
there's a little short ass legs because
evolution dictated that this animal
change.
I mean,
and that happened over 2000 years.
There's a fish in the Amazon that comes
out of the fucking water and walks.
It's awesome.
It's crazy.
And finds another waterhole and then
there's this fucking bird that eats it,
that looks like a goddamn dinosaur.
It's a six foot tall evil giant bird
with this crazy big ass fucking beak,
like this big killing machine attached
to its face and it's got these dead eyes
like these dead crazy dinosaur eagle
eyes and it jacks this fucking old
dinosaur walking fish.
And you're like,
Whoa,
that's a nutty goddamn place.
That's the same planet we live on.
You're saying that old video of like the
Eagle,
like killing all those goats,
like throwing them off the cliffs.
It's awesome.
It's ego just it's like on top of a
cliff and there's all these goats and
it's just like grabbing him and throwing
him off the cliff and eat them.
It could barely carry them,
but it's dragging them like.
It's like you're doing it on purpose.
It couldn't kill them if it was just on
flat land.
It knows it's going to kill them by
dragging them off the rock.
I mean,
that's incredible.
Yeah,
it's smart to man,
like whatever this blackbirds are where
they have.
They use tools.
You've seen that?
Yeah.
I've,
I've seen them do all kinds of creepy
shit.
I had a stake in A.
I was trying to,
um,
a thought out and I put it on.
It was in the rap,
you know,
from the supermarket and I put it on a
stone outside my house for a minute,
maybe a minute.
I came out and these crows worth fucking
it up.
They've me.
They watched me put that out and then
they swooped in and look at it and I
think that is meet this dumb
motherfucker,
left some meat out.
Like there's no way he's that stupid.
He left some meat out.
I'm telling you it's me.
Let's eat it.
And they landed on and just her fuck it
up.
And I came out,
there was two of them just fucking up
the state.
Wow.
They're so clever.
It's crazy.
And a rat witnessing it now of flying
rat.
Even flying like a pigeon.
Pigeon magic.
We're flying rats around here.
How horrible that would be.
There were pigeons,
pigeons flying rats.
Unless you raise them yourself in the
cute.
I'd been putting bird feed out lately at
my backyard in the bird feed.
I put out a attracts these little
canaries now.
Have just little canaries everywhere.
I've never in Ohio,
they don't have canaries or
fellows.
Very specific.
Have either of you guys tried j dot w,
h o
when I heard about this the other day is
that there's a,
there's a topic on your form about it.
Um,
I can't remember.
What is this?
Oh my God.
Oh,
here.
Here's how crazy you internet kids.
Are you coming up with new ways to get
high?
It's an analgesic chemical from the
Amino alkalol,
alcohol and node.
How do you say that?
And I don't know.
Yeah,
no,
I'll key lineal family at which acts as
a cannabinoid,
blah,
blah.
Well,
it must be something that gets you
fucked up.
I'm sure there's a lot of those things
to a different new things.
You know,
this sounds crazy coming from someone
who's done as many soccer dogs as I
have,
but I think the shit that you should do
is the shift that people have been doing
for thousands of years.
You know,
you can't go wrong with San Pedro.
Cactus,
you can't go wrong with cannabis.
Mushrooms.
You can't go wrong with those things.
IOWASCA.
You can't go wrong.
I mean,
you can't go wrong.
You lose your fucking marbles.
Don't listen to me.
What I'm saying is you knew stuff like,
you know,
hey man,
try this new shit.
Scientists fucking in NASA labs,
man.
It just came up with it.
Um,
no,
don't,
don't do anything that people haven't
been doing a long time.
Don't fuck with some new shit.
They just invented tests and you smoke
it and it makes you want to fuck
animals.
You know,
who the hell knows?
All the old Indians.
They were,
have their Beta testers.
That was their shit.
The San Pedro cactus masculine.
I've never done that.
If you ever done it was just crazy that
these things are illegal.
I mean,
Bill Hicks had a great line about that.
Like isn't there something fucked up
about making nature against the law?
You know,
it was just totally,
totally true.
I mean,
how could you tell someone that they
can't have a life form that exists
naturally on this planet,
whether it's cannabis or mushrooms or
you know,
anything,
anything that grows naturally,
you can buy this and Sonya,
anything that's affects your
consciousness.
You can buy stuff that's poisonous,
like you can legally have a bunch of
different plants that can kill you,
a bunch of different plants.
You know,
it's like you just having marijuana in
your backyard is not proof that you're
eating marijuana or using it and if you
have all these poisonous plants in your
backyard,
nobody would even bat an eye.
And that's the same thing.
It's not.
I mean it's a personal use issue.
You know,
it's,
it's really so weird that people allow
in this day and age with all the
information that we have,
allow plants to be illegal.
Man,
it's fucking pretty incredible ants.
It's pretty incredible.
It's fucking really bizarre that we
have.
We enforce it so strictly.
It's such a strong ethic in our culture
that if we catch you using certain
plants that have nothing to do with me,
they're not effective.
Not at all.
But if I catch you with these plants,
I'm allowed by our laws to q and a cage.
How crazy is that?
If you haven't yet giant ass bag of
mushrooms and you are driving on your
way to the woods and a cop pulls you
over and says,
what are you doing?
He's like,
well,
I'm about to have a spiritual experience
with the Lord.
The Capa go,
what the fuck you're talking about?
Well,
I have these mushrooms that I'm going to
go out to get the fuck out of the car.
Get out of the car,
he'll handcuff you.
Fucking idiot.
You're telling me about this.
I'm just letting you know,
man.
I'm just a nature is natural.
It grows on the earth and it's shut the
fuck up.
Shut up.
I don't want to hear I wanna hear your
hippie bullshit.
Get in the fucking car.
I just hit the mother with this stupid
fuck.
This guy told me he had mushrooms on
him.
How high is he?
No wonder you.
Let's go to salaries and then they meet
up and they feel good for locking this
guy in a cage for having plants on them.
Yeah,
that's bizarre.
Two thousand 10.
That's strange.
I mean it's.
It's very hard to believe if that's the
case.
What's.
It's really strange.
That 2010 is that we're going towards
2020.
That's just craziness.
It was crazy.
Just the sound of it.
This guy says it's because of money
though.
Yeah.
It's definitely because of money,
but it's just,
it's amazing.
You know.
Here's the best example of how it's for
sure.
Politicians are whores.
Best example,
nobody talks about cigarettes.
If cigarettes was,
if al Qaeda was killing 400,000
people in America every year,
Holy Shit.
With the war against al Qaeda heat up,
it will be gigantic as it is there.
They're killing people.
Most of them that they've killed,
you know,
unless she lifts the Alex Jones
government.
But most of them are in other countries.
I mean,
in this country alone,
I'll Kinda is not aware of Jack and
people,
but cigarettes are cigarettes.
She'll 400 fucking thousand people a
year.
I mean,
compare something you use for personal
use to al Qaeda is ridiculous.
Absolutely,
but my point is like it's very
dangerous.
Marijuana doesn't do that.
Even alcoholism killed that.
Many people think about how fucked up
alcohol gets you and alcohol poisoning
or alcohol deaths.
It's not nearly as high as cigarettes.
Cigarettes is a motherfucker and it's so
hard to kick.
Right?
You went back on him,
right?
Yeah.
Brian terms.
That was a year.
He's done it a couple times in.
One little thing will set that trigger
off in the back of head.
It's mostly stress stuff.
It's horrible,
but meanwhile it's totally legal.
And did we talk about the oxycontin
express last week?
We did,
right?
God,
we talked about cigarettes too.
We talked to.
These are important issues.
If you haven't seen the oxygen come
express,
get on that shit.
Find it on,
on online.
I think it's on youtube.
The whole thing is,
and it's one of those directors version,
so that whole things on youtube.
So this week.
And you're at the Ice House?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We're doing comedy this weekend.
Bitches making it happen.
He's going to be a job at the Ice House
in Pasadena.
Uh,
this Friday we're doing two shows there
and Saturday we're doing two shows.
This guy says dmt is not easy to
extract.
Well,
you ain't no super secret scientist.
Are you?
Do you ever smoke banana plc?
These motherfuckers?
Yeah.
I smoked a lot of shit when I was young.
Stupid.
I was trying to get high.
I smoked like bamboo leaves.
It was horrible.
Very harsh on the lungs too.
Birds can be scary.
They are on acid.
Oh yeah.
Good point.
Amazing Kush.
The bird can be super scary.
Period,
man.
You were looking at Eagle's eye like you
ever seen a dude that has like a pet
eagle.
We've those talk shows and they get
close up on an eagles.
Hi,
this girl,
I just got an owl as a pen and have you
seen him as a murderer?
Murderer.
And it just sits in their back room on
that.
The shower thing y'all.
That ain't cool.
That's a predator.
It's crazy.
That's a real like animals look all
fluffy and cool and everything because
everybody thinks about them from those
Goddamn tootsie roll commercials,
tootsie pops.
That's not.
No,
that's a fucking Predator thing about
people where we take these evil
predators and we change what they are.
Like polar bears.
We got them selling ice cream.
Nicola polar bears are fucking monsters.
Polar bears cover their nose when
they're sneaking up on Eskimo villages
so that they can't see the black.
That's awesome.
Do they?
They.
They learned how to do that.
Hunting seals.
They take their nose and they.
They hang over the edge of a glacier,
a floating ice raft,
and they hang over the edge so that
these seals don't see them.
They see white.
Everything is white.
If they see that black nose,
they figured out that seals can see the
black nose.
That's how fucking evil they are,
and we got them selling ice cream and
coca cola,
tony the tiger.
That's about chimps,
man.
Bj and the bear.
This tooling around with a little pet
monkey.
How can Bj and the bear?
How come behr number eight,
anybody's face off.
How come Behr?
Never tried to bite some dude's asshole
out by thinking.
I think that that monkey ended up doing
that with net.
The monkey that was retired here in Los
Angeles.
They,
they always retirement,
they get older because you can't control
the old males.
You can't control them,
aren't mirrors to ancestors are.
It doesn't matter if you raise them.
They're completely wild.
You cannot stop that.
That lady just thought just because she
was putting a diaper on this champ,
you know,
and given Xanax and she would give it
wine and shit.
It was like a fake boyfriend.
She had like this fake monkey boyfriend
and she thought she had the thing under
control.
Then they just decided eat either
friend's face.
It's like,
I don't fucking like you.
I don't like you.
He didn't.
I mean there was no fight.
There weren't brawling.
She didn't hit him with a rock.
He shouldn't.
Shit is attacked her an eight or face.
Whoa.
Even dogs don't usually do that.
You know,
you got a guy who's got a crazy dog.
They don't attack your friends.
How often does that happen?
I say kids.
Yeah,
because they think kids are animals.
They don't respect them.
That all that shit about my cat really
freaks me out.
Talking Shit about him.
I can't kill anything.
You know,
if you have a pet monkey,
a little monkey like that big,
would you be safe leaving room?
This fluffy cat shouldn't murder that
thing.
I come home,
it's got to be all hanging out and she'd
be looking at me like she's my friend.
Hi.
They will not even like,
she's evil.
Poor little monkey was little monkey
family.
She'd kill them to the little monkey.
Babies are merciless.
It should be rolling around the dead
bodies.
Especially with her,
cause she's got real close.
She's not declawed.
He's declawed.
They all have these things I just found.
I don't know if I told you this or not,
where they go over the claw used glue,
any put glue in these little claws and
it goes over the claw.
So they think they have closed still,
but it's weird rabbit with him,
but after awhile they pop off,
they pop off and pop off.
Quick Park,
keep choosing off to late Jack and
everything sucks.
Yeah,
I wouldn't let him keep his claws.
I don't care.
I think it's.
I think it's fucked up to take the
youtube video.
They actually cut off a knuckle.
It cut off this part.
That's craziness.
My cat killed a rabbit when it was a
kitten.
Damn,
that's a.
that's a rough story.
Asian alien.
I believe it though.
Cats are ruthless.
I grew up in a knot who'd wear a cro,
could talk.
His name was car and he would come when
called.
Wow.
You know what if I had never read
anything about crows or watched a video
and I'd be like,
that guy's crazy.
Crows coming to pet crow.
Totally the same.
It's not like they're all black.
Right.
You know when they figured out you have
food,
you know.
I find it weird when people have no
worlds as pets or raccoons.
Raccoons are crazy to see that one video
where a raccoon or a dog or wrestling,
they usually fighting to the death and
now you know raccoons.
Fuck dogs up,
man.
They've ripped them apart.
Yeah,
they're scary animals.
I mean,
I see him all the time or in my
neighborhood.
Raccoons and skunks and rats books.
We lost to history that I would have
changed the world.
That's long articles that good.
I'll check it out.
All right.
We're going to read some questions here.
One year.
No cigarettes.
This guy says all it cost me was a
girlfriend.
The dog.
She took my,
my waistline and my sanity.
Wow.
And you get hit by a bus tomorrow.
Deserved the cigarettes after she left
you or you couldn't afford them after
she left you or you quit the cigarettes
and because you couldn't cigarettes.
You went crazy and you were like aggro.
And then she left you.
Is that what you're saying?
That she took the dog.
It's took your waistline,
but the wasteland.
That's good.
Right?
You want to lose,
lose some weight?
Probably.
Unless you like one of those dudes in
the guts.
Apparently there's a lot of gay dudes to
them.
Electronic guts like that.
They'd like to have a clicker.
They gotten cock.
I think like those ladies,
Zack.
Zack got some,
you know,
I mean there's fetishes just like some
dudes are like really in a feet.
Some dudes are really into like girls
and spiff specific type of toenails and
like come on girls toes,
you know,
I think with gay dudes and just get into
a certain thing like they see some crazy
homophobic trucker is all mapped out at
the truck stop and they just wish they
could just suck his cock because he
hates them.
He hates them.
There's something about them.
It just turns the gay guy on.
That's my theory.
That's fine.
That guy with this big fat gut and suck
that Dick.
What?
I love people like this.
Somebody just asked,
you know what?
They've been trying to see your tattoo
for three weeks.
They've been asking now,
wouldn't you think you can see that when
this person does google,
if he really cared that much.
Joe Rogan Tattoo at the.
That's the kind of people I hate.
You know?
It's like,
well,
I don't hate,
but I hate people.
When they asked me all these questions,
I'm like,
man,
if you're fucking google broken.
That shit happens to me all the time.
Yeah.
People,
there's some people that just don't have
good friends.
Good.
Talked to lazy fingers.
No.
Yeah.
The only problem with marijuana,
there is one problem with marijuana and
it's some of the marijuana community.
A lot of churches,
you know,
a lot of mooches and dirty hippies.
Brian left this insist,
you and me now.
Do you think I should get rid of him?
So I kick him out of the room and just
have it all about us.
Say,
listen man,
you did your part today.
That's been my people.
Yeah.
This dude is saying,
um,
I did a job.
Ct Dirt says I did a job and these
people fed wild raccoons and they
scratch at the door like a cat.
Wow.
That's crazy.
That's nuts,
man.
Makes Sense.
I've seen squirrels that you could feed.
There's a park in north Hollywood and if
you break peanuts of you,
especially,
you lie down.
So the squirrel doesn't feel like you
know,
you're in a threatening position to
chase after him.
You know,
you lie down on your stomach and you
hold up in the fucking scroll.
Come up to you real gingerly,
making sure you're not crazy and he'll
take that peanut and some dudes that the
squirrels.
No really well though to sit right in
front of the dude and eat his peanuts
like right there.
Like this one,
there was this one old Chinese guy that
apparently goes to the park everyday and
he brings penis and so he's sitting
there with these peanuts.
These girls are coming right up to him.
They're just holding his hand while
they're taking the peanut.
Like he's their friend.
Like they're not worried about him at
all.
It's kind of crazy,
crazy saying.
By the way,
the Jedis is that new digital camera I
reviewed.
If you guys are
helium to say this before,
if you ever want to like buy something
like in in he know that he's reviewed
it.
You got to watch his reviews.
He's crazy.
There's something wrong with him and he
gets like super into the technical
aspects of anything.
Technology like phones and like his
reviews of phones.
He kills those guys at engadget.
Those bitches.
You can't hang with Brian.
The problem is a lot of these websites
are getting money,
you know,
they're getting like they're going to
get.
Well,
not saying that engadget does.
No,
no,
but like if they've reviewed favorably,
say like an apple product,
then the next time apple has a product
out,
they'll give them like an exclusive.
Because you know,
a lot of these websites don't want to
bash her,
tell the truth because they don't want
to ruin future products and stuff like
that.
So anyways,
this is a new camera in world works is a
new camera.
Films Hd.
It's high quality hd,
60 frames per second.
I have the whole review at red band
Dotcom Stereo microphones.
If you're looking for a small digital
video camera,
this shit.
What's the model name?
Brian?
It's Sony DSC t x seven and red band.
Red Bin Dot com.
I have the whole review there.
This dude says,
podcast or a girl says podcasts from the
sensory deprivation tank.
Maybe that would be a fucking cool thing
to do.
You know what?
Actually it sounds like that.
Would it be?
Would it sound like that?
It was.
Is there a way that I could have
somebody recording sound in there?
Well,
you know,
he can't get away and then we can hook
them.
Might put a microphone right at two next
to it.
But I mean there was some more both,
you know and all that stuff because it's
echoing in there.
Yeah.
But who wants to do.
Why?
Oh,
you mean just lay there and talk?
Yeah.
Well we could just turn off the lights
here and you can talk and.
No,
no.
I'm going to totally do that.
Winning,
that defeat the purpose of being in
isolation tank.
No.
Okay.
You will be too focused on talking to
people.
No,
no,
because it would be talking to people.
Your mind would work so much better than
it works with sitting in a normal
environment like here talking to you and
sitting on a couch and lights and the
laptop and all this input coming in.
You don't realize how much this has an
effect on your ability to see things
clearly and you see things very,
very clear in that tank and I think if
you're in that tank and you just start
talking,
it's going to fuck up a little bit of
the experience because you're going to
hear things.
You hear yourself in both in your ears,
so hear to your ears.
Can you hear it?
Okay?
Had you've lost your mind,
but I think it'd be kind of cool.
I will do that.
We're going to figure out a way where I
can do a podcast
someday from the sensory deprivation
tank and by Sunday I mean like within a
month.
I don't mean like when I'm old and ready
to die.
Hey,
gay ban the original question three
weeks,
two weeks ago was why does joe always
wear long sleeve will hae a retard go
google that because I bet you joe's
answer that
wow.
Totally out.
That was really.
It was unnecessary.
He called me gay man.
I'm allowed to say something.
Wow,
you're an asshole.
But he's looking.
I can't take them seriously because he
says Brian is a f,
k,
a whole.
If you asked me,
well,
I'll never going to ask you anything if
that's what you write and fkk.
That's really you.
I can't talk to you dude.
Brian's the third wheel.
How?
How dare you?
Ryan's very talented
ipns.
Too much negative energy.
I think it doesn't have a negative
negative energies.
The safest,
most non-dangerous negative energy ever.
He's a nice guy.
Leave him alone.
You fucking creeps.
Why won't Dana let you show your town,
the UFC?
No,
it's not that.
It's just,
it's a distraction.
It's not necessary.
You know,
it's not about me when I'm on the UFC,
it's 100 percent about those dudes that
are fighting.
I just try to do my part,
my commentary and explain and be
enthusiastic and be appreciative,
but it's not about me,
you know?
That's why I dress like such a retard.
I'm not trying to shy away
looking at my cuff links,
looking at diamonds,
trying to look good at all.
I just try to just do my job.
What's important is not me.
What's important is these,
uh,
these guys fucking throwing their bones
at each other in the octagon.
It's not me.
What kind of we did we smoke before the
show?
Well,
Mr.
federal agent.
That's one of the funniest things that I
like when someone will ask a stupid
question and someone will go like,
laziest homo ever laziest pedo ever
lasers.
Dea Age.
Never.
And it's become like a standard was
like,
I don't know who was the first one to do
it,
but I've seen it many forums.
I don't know where it started from,
but so many people do that now.
Someone will ask a dumb question and
someone will China,
you know,
China with that.
I think it's really funny,
like whenever people ask like drug
questions,
like,
hey man from Tallahassee,
where can I get dmt?
And some of them,
right?
Laziest dea agent.
It's become a part of it.
Would you say that's the lexicon?
How would you say to them?
Yeah.
What else?
Brian?
Me.
Your questions,
uh,
kind of weed.
You smoke before a show man,
you wouldn't smoke.
Kind of weedy.
The kind of comes from.
That's
a funny thing that was talking about
marijuana supporting these Mexican drug
cartels.
What are you talking about,
Steve?
But the part that I buy,
I bought this guys growing right over
there.
You can go to his house.
I'll show you the fuck he talking about.
He's not al Qaeda and he's not a Mexican
drug lord.
And he's right down the street.
He's a nice guy and he's got plants.
He'll sell you water zone.
We put fertilizer and she does a great
job.
The fuck man.
And it's great.
There's a website called web
tracker.com.
We met this guys in San Francisco,
but each store has a uh,
own forum and so like,
uh,
you find which stores near Your House
and then you go to.
This has like a little website just for
that store and everyday they'll say
we've got train wreck and we,
this is our specials,
you know,
and stuff like that.
And it's great.
People Review it.
Oh,
it's incredible.
Amazing that.
So at this point it's so free here in
California that it literally is like pot
is legal.
It's just,
it's very close.
Right?
Like what's in between,
like,
like what's,
well they've passed one step of a
multistep process to making it illegal
for responsible use for adults over.
You know,
I'll probably be over 18 or 21.
I mean it should be over 18 I think.
I think that's reasonable.
You know like alcohol I think.
I think alcohol should be 18 with
supervision,
meaning like,
you know,
it should be okay for like your dad
gives you a beer when you're 18 years
old,
you know,
or you come with your dad to a place
where his buddy has a bar and you know,
just going to call him a boy beers
number that'll be here before,
you know,
slowly introduce them into the world and
make it like it's no big deal.
You've got to learn how to hold your
liquor.
Okay.
I understand.
And from your fucking father,
you know what I'm saying?
Like as a young man,
I let him take away all of the mystique
of what alcohol really is.
And that should be the same thing with
the real problem with any thing that
affects your mind is that we don't have
enough people out there that are
explaining to people how to manage that
shit.
And with alcoholics,
at least they have alcoholics anonymous
and you know,
they can help guide you back on the
right track.
But you know,
there's no,
no people out there that are telling
you,
you know,
like explaining to you how to
incorporate.
We'd successfully in your life for the
maximum benefits,
you know,
I mean shit,
maybe we should write a book about that
because it's a fucking good idea because
what really we need in this country,
and it sounds like all spiritual,
crazy Voodoo,
but we need Sharmane and what a shaman
is in like in the Amazon rainforest of
the guys would make the IOWASCA.
It's a dude who's been there,
done that.
He's done it a thousand times.
She knows what to expect.
He knows what's gonna happen.
He's not scared of it.
He enjoys and welcomes the experience.
He could talk you through it.
You don't have to freak the fuck out.
This guy is going to help you,
he's going to sing songs,
going to comfort you,
they're going to play the drums and
you're going to get to talk to dead
people.
I mean,
that's what it is.
It's a showman and we need a shaman for
marijuana and we really could use a
shotgun for alcohol to this.
She would be someone who culturally
explained to the group.
I mean,
there should be like expressed as an
ethic through the entire human community
that it's wrong to be drunk and
obnoxious and be a fucking douche bag
and ruined other people's good time and
that should be something we all agree
upon.
Shouldn't be something funny like,
Oh,
maybe I told him he got drunk and rip
the girl shirt.
That should be horrifying to everyone
involved.
We should.
All that is is the reason why we don't
address that is we have this crazy way
of looking at drugs.
We look at drugs like [inaudible] and
they're all bad.
They're all under this.
Same is one gigantic carpet of
everything's bad for you,
so it's not necessarily bad for you.
It's only bad for some people.
It's good for some people.
The experience is benefit you then make
your life more interesting.
Should Sharman be driving while giving
advice?
Do you have to promise me if you get 18
year old and then that person just got
their license two years ago,
they don't.
Not to fucking drive,
you know,
drive reckless.
Yeah.
It drive too fast and then they're not
good at it.
That was me.
I was terrible driver.
So lucky and I have a dwi.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you ever get one?
No.
Never got one.
Yeah.
I never drove that drunk,
but I probably could have like,
you know,
the legal limit is like
I try to do one day or an hour pretty
much.
It's one bear.
Yeah.
Have you had one beer and you get pulled
over 20 minutes later?
I bet you could probably get nailed.
Maybe if you say borderline
for a half an hour.
The second beer.
Right.
That's crazy.
But with a lot of people,
that's good man.
You really should.
They really shouldn't be driving anthony
from opie and Anthony has a really
interesting point.
It's like,
what if I'm good but I drive drunk,
but that's not a good point.
If you kill a kid,
you know,
slammed into a family.
Well I would say I'm better than average
driving drunk,
but you know,
there's no test for that.
You know,
unfortunately they came to sit you down
and go,
okay,
you got to play fucking pole position
for an hour and skills.
That's thing about marijuana.
If people are just more cautious when
they're it,
you know,
people think that marijuana affects
your,
your reaction.
It doesn't,
it really doesn't.
I smoked marijuana and I do Jujitsu all
the time.
So does Eddie Bravo.
So like a bunch of different,
like really high level Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu guys,
I forget about me.
I know guys that are like world
championship,
black belts that love to get high and
then go do Jujitsu.
Like it makes them connected to the
movements better.
It's makes you,
it's your very coordinated when you're
high,
but it's more like we were talking about
earlier with like being paranoid.
Paranoia is like too much information.
You don't know how to manage it.
It's not that it's a bad thing,
it's a,
you're just getting too much info.
You're not keeping up with it.
That's where it all comes from.
Dan,
check this out.
His cousin was going to jail,
but after having the t,
two Duis,
but the policeman that arrested him died
and so now you know,
there's no proof or whatever.
That's crazy luck
for everybody.
But the cop.
Yeah.
Joe,
you're going to be on celebrity rehab
the next few years.
Oh,
totally.
Have you watched that show?
Yes.
I watched one episode because Stan hope
was mocking.
Dr Drew.
I said,
I let me check this
out.
It's like,
wow,
what a train wreck.
I mean,
it's crazy.
It's fun to watch.
I'm not addicted.
Is there anything that I could stop?
I don't have a problem with anything
right now.
I used to have,
you know,
my real problem has never been drugs.
My real problem is games.
I have a serious addiction to video
games and to pool pool I think is a
little bit more meditation because it's
like a lot of handoff coordination and
you have to steady your nerves and it's
all,
you know,
controlling the ball.
But I get obsessed with games.
I got what I get when I play.
I used to play quake and I used to play
no bullshit eight hours a day at least
every day I was online.
I loved it and I've,
I'm avoiding that on purpose.
So if I had like a PR thing that I
needed to kick at any point in my life,
it was never drugs and drugs weren't
ruining my life,
but video games were kind of running my
life.
Not ruining it,
but they were.
It was becoming an,
an obsession.
The problem is I enjoy the fuck out of
it.
Quake is so goddamn fun.
You know,
we're gonna try to create a capsule.
You never.
What's that?
You're trying to quit caffeine.
Yeah,
I've quit.
Caffeine should.
It's hard.
It is hard.
Or,
you know,
when I realized that I needed to quit,
I was writing a blog a day,
you know,
that one time before a film my special,
I wrote a blog every day.
So I was up every night really late
because that's when I write my best
shit.
So every night I was drinking coffee at
like 10:00
and I was,
I mean,
this kind of coffee too.
I don't fuck around.
I use a French press,
you know,
it's like I grind my own coffee,
you get a bird grinder and I give these
beans only from these Kona beans from
Hawaii and my favorite.
This coffee will fuck your world up.
This shit is strong and I will take it
at like 10:00
at night.
And Man I couldn't get to bed until
five,
6:00
in the morning.
And then when they finally did crash I
felt like shit the next day and I did it
a bunch of days in a row that I tried to
stop and we're going to stop.
I got these serious headaches but dull,
like pressing headaches.
Like it didn't even feel like coffee
could fix him.
It felt like I just
like a short circuit.
My brain
fuck is calling me podcast.
Perfect.
My apologies.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't you feel less energy at doing
exercising after you smoke weed?
No,
I'm the opposite.
I've,
especially if it's a good sativa,
people that are outside of California,
most of what you're getting is called
indigo and indigo is a very different
kind of marijuana.
Then Sativa.
There's two types.
There's Endeca,
which is like relaxed couch.
We'd like,
oh dude,
just go and chill.
You know what I'm saying?
That's Oji Kush weed.
That's the way that makes you want to
eat and fuck up your diet man diet,
you know,
but sativa is,
I want to watch a documentary.
Sativa is,
you know,
you want to watch the cosmos and see
Carl Sagan on TV and cross seg and by
the way,
small pot every day.
That was the shit.
And the crossing was a huge
activist and advocate of marijuana and
enhancing perceptions with bx.
This guy.
Shit,
I understand that you and Brian had a
little falling out.
Okay.
Let's just be nice though.
There's no need to get crazy.
People are so emo.
Yeah.
There's a lot of email people.
The mark.
Aiden,
I wonder which God has got the Mark
Gaydon now a lot of people have the
markets.
Mark.
No,
I heard it's not.
Sounds like a goddamn questions.
This guy says I grow two strains.
Sativa.
You're right.
Joe.
First of all,
don't ever say your and spell it like
that.
You argue why?
Oh,
you.
He didn't spell.
You are,
which is the gayest way ever.
What are you a little girl texting your.
I hate that.
Why?
Oh,
you.
And it's not an art.
There's an apostrophe and,
and there's an Ra.
It's short for you are.
It's not short for something.
I own you motherfucker.
Have you been playing quake live at all?
I fucked that up all the time.
Now everybody,
you were your mistake.
You're writing.
Especially if you can type fairly
quickly.
You just things come on.
Fuck that.
So I was thinking about getting a
regular phone,
a skinny like razor phone on verizon
network and then getting the IPAD.
So like if I'm like out my car,
pull up my ipad,
have a better internet but have a solid
phone.
Hm,
go.
So you're going to go back.
Go back.
I think just as well.
But what if someone sends you a picture?
A video on your phone?
Some asshole.
I can't believe this.
Check this out.
Did that now?
Yeah.
You know,
why did they go with 18 and t?
Well you don't have to,
you know,
here's the thing.
No one's thinking of this.
They have those modifiers now.
So you just have your mind,
a verizon network and now you have
horizon anywhere you go,
you know?
Really?
Yeah.
They have these boxes that connect and
then broadcast wireless.
It's called,
if I remember I showed you,
they're about this big.
So if you have a little case,
like a statue that you have your ipad
in,
just have that,
throw that in there,
turn it on and you have verizon.
Wherever you go to this motherfucker
just hacking the system bitches.
And that's another thing that's going to
be big man.
Persons are going to have to come back
because of this thing.
You know you're a big advocate of the
marriage.
I actually bought a domain name and I
told her I was addicted to domain names.
I bought IPAD sling.
So if you know anyone that's like,
oh shit,
you know anyone that makes versus just
my laptop.
No,
I don't know anybody that makes purses.
Guys don't wear
man,
man.
Man,
Pouch those,
those men bags,
they look like a fucking purse to me.
Fanny pack looks like a manly choice.
Family Pact doesn't though.
The Chin.
All your stuff is right there.
So one wants something just unzipped and
he gave it to him.
Right.
See I liked my little man purse that
looks because it's made for guns.
So it looks like a gun.
Satua base will fit the IPAD so it
doesn't look natural.
It looks like it was for jewelry.
No makeup.
I haven't reviewed that.
Stick in and mirrors.
Yeah,
but you like,
like you got to go do the Disney family
asked fucking fanny pack.
I like fanny packs are wearing all the
time.
She didn't have a company and then you
can also sell ice or ipad slang.
I don't want to sell them Ipad,
sling and not buying the I pad,
but I,
if I didn't have a kindle,
I would see what you're saying and.
But wait,
if you want to buy a portable DVD player
for the car or something,
we're like,
you want a good one though?
It was like,
don't you pay a little extra if you
could download the movies while you're
in the car?
Okay.
First of all,
how dope would it be if you had a screen
in your car and stopped?
No.
You can do that.
You could make that screen in your car
and install it as a screen.
Yeah,
you could totally do.
That was thing that on the way over,
imagine that gps.
That might be the greatest thing ever
and it's got to see how many inches is
that?
It's nine point seven inches across.
So thin.
They could just sit,
fit it right in your car and you feel
your dashboard fitted for it.
Whoa.
You know what's really funny is a lot of
people are bashing it.
That's not widescreen.
Well alright there's going to be the bar
on the top and the bottom.
So they wanted a white skin.
So what do you mean?
They wanted us to.
They wanted them to chop off the top and
bottom or make it bigger.
If you make it bigger than that thing
would be this big but widescreen.
So it's like a letterbox thing.
When you watch a video you see a little
black stripe
but that's what they had to do.
That's what did to people don't get
widescreen.
It'll kill it.
It definitely is better to have
something that you can read books and
watch movies on if you look at it that
way.
But the way I am video games still's not
that appealing to me because I already
have a laptop and if I'm going to spend
time like what is it going to give me?
The.
The laptop's not going to.
I can watch movies on the laptop.
I'm,
which will be done.
That.
What else can I do?
I get online on that.
I get on my laptop better.
So what am I doing with it?
The applications really and why?
No,
all right.
It's the size of a book,
so what they're saying is that what if
you use it like you have a razor phone
in your pocket,
you go into the comedy club and you have
this little thing the size of a little
notepad.
It's in a little leather pouch.
Him keep that bitch in your pocket.
You're going to pretend that you going
to carry this thing around with you
everywhere.
Well,
no,
you throw it in the car.
It's like a.
It looks like a little book.
It's a little book,
you know,
so you throw it in the car so that you
could use it when you're out,
when you're out.
You if you have it in the like Steve
Jobs,
people are going to bring interesting to
restaurants and instead of texting
they're going to be sitting there moving
books,
doing little g emails,
checking their calendars.
Steve Jobs,
you bashed.
I think people are Basset and freaking
out about it because there's a couple of
things that it doesn't do or doesn't do
flash and stuff,
but that's another reason.
Have jobs just fucking this up.
I think on the market people are going
to go crazy for it.
Analogy.
Alright,
let's read some questions from these
people gears of war.
Fuck you have.
That game was awesome.
That's another game.
I'm scared of that game.
I don't want to get locked in that world
of playing that Shit online everyday to
fun,
man.
We got a chance to see that early on.
We got a chance.
We were in North Carolina and I met
cliff.
He be from epic games and he got us in
and we gotta look at the models of.
Gives a war way before it was released.
It was fucking crazy.
The new stuff.
They're working on these new entities to
do so insane.
Like he,
he showed us a demo,
some of the stuff and the guys at ID
software did to Tim Wilson and Todd
Hollingshead and John Carmack and those
guys.
Those guys are super cool.
They,
they let us come and check out all the
new stuff they're doing.
That's my favorite all time games quick.
But like I said,
I'm scared.
Did you know that there is a,
uh,
they did a report on a browser,
crashes on computers and I think it was
85 percent of all browser crashes were
because of Flash.
Whoa,
that's a big number.
Whoa.
80 five.
Because other than flashed you got
javascript.
He got a couple of things,
but 85 percent of that's crazy.
Like how has that allowed people to say
people are freaking out about something.
It's a plugin,
you know,
html five point.
Oh,
is about to come out which will make
flash pretty much unnecessary.
How's it make less on this?
Well see the problem is they started
using flash back in the day because that
was an easy way to take video,
put it on the Internet so anyone can
watch it because people's Internet
connections kind of sucked and you know,
and it was in one format.
What html?
Five point.
Oh days.
It's pretty much make,
I think it's h,
two point six for like the video.
We'll just play in the browser,
kind of like our gift works,
you know,
like animated Gif will work no matter
what because it's made in the coating of
the browser.
So this will make videos and stuff like
that.
Just be in the,
in the coding and just work right now.
So guess who's who gets,
who's making our editing,
the html l point,
five point zero coding.
This is kind of interesting.
A guy that works at Google and the guy
that works at Apple,
so you have long had this theory that
um,
that there's a battle going on between a
apple and flash.
And you think that one of the reasons
why apple has such a hard time working
with flash and make it shitty on purpose
so that people move away from flash.
Well,
I think that's a good good theory
definitely.
But the big thing is,
is that like no one in silicon valley
works together like Amazon and apple and
they're all not working together as a
team.
They're all like having to fight and do.
And you know,
like the opposite of what this person's
doing.
Like,
like if a flash releases a new plugin
that works with firefox and or whatever
it but doesn't work for safari,
they're trying to work for safari.
Safari changes something and then it
fucks all their shit up.
You know,
it's constantly like that with
everything in silicon valley because
they don't work together.
They work together.
Just thing is going to go understand
seeing conspiracy behind.
If I'm sensing flashes getting pushed
out for some reason.
Mostly because of the security reasons.
It's very open a,
you can get hacked and security with
flash and stuff like that.
Uh,
and I think it's getting pushed out,
especially when html five point.
Oh,
comes out,
which is probably coming soon.
Hey she.
Five point.
Oh,
can't do with flash does buddy.
And it's proprietary CODEC.
It's what?
This is what this guy says.
Filbert double o seven.
Yeah.
Go,
go google search tml.
Five point zero.
Go look at wikipedia or whatever,
you know,
even explain it in there.
It's pretty much known that once html
five point,
oh,
comes out.
That flashed for the most part,
it's going to
be hurting.
Okay.
Well,
the gauntlet has been thrown down.
A challenge has been made.
Youtube has already switched over to all
their videos to five point.
Oh,
what is this guy's asking?
What?
So as Vimeo,
vimeo.com,
I believe,
just switched over to a to five point.
Oh,
ready?
Meaning that's why Youtube now works on
your iphone.
Hold on a second.
This guy's asking the question.
What's with the sensoring on this social
message board?
Does.
What does the sensor is like?
If you try to twitter or something and
you swear or on this,
would it change it a maybe?
Is that why that guy wrote that fucking
like that.
Oh,
maybe.
I don't know.
Is that true folks?
You can't swear on this.
It's probably a setting.
If there is.
Oh it has to be a setting.
Please tell him that setting
that is,
you know,
people don't think that's a big deal.
Like I always make a big deal out of the
fact that,
you know,
censorship,
certain words,
you know,
and people say,
what's the big deal?
You know,
why?
Why do you have to be rude?
Why can't you just not say those
particular words or in your own certain
people or in certain situations like
that's a way of controlling us.
It's nonsense.
It makes no sense whatsoever,
and words don't mean anything other than
intention.
What's important is that you are
expressing your intention.
You're expressing what you're.
What you're thinking,
that the idea of magic words is it's
poison to the language.
It's terrible to have words that you
can't use around certain people and you
can't use.
When you broadcast them,
you'd be fined hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
That is a just a gigantic distraction
that's complete total mind control.
It's a technique that they're using to
try to control the population.
There's no other way around it.
There's why outs is censorship,
is what it offends people.
Why isn't offend people?
You don't have to listen to it.
The government's going after it.
Why they're going after they're going
after it because some people are very
offended by it.
Whether it's religious people or you
know,
really conservative people,
but why?
Why the offended by it?
It's,
it's nonsense.
It's a fucking huge distraction.
It's just a word.
Whether you say I fucked her or I had
sex with her,
you can't say I fucked her.
Like,
is that really hurting someone's
feelings?
So.
So what happened,
uh,
on the,
you know,
the night that you proposed to your
wife?
Well,
I fucked her.
You know what I mean?
It's not a bad.
Well,
it's actually,
they're the same thing.
You're saying the same thing.
Like it's not offending me if you say
you fucked her,
you know,
if you say I that fucking hurt,
I'm not going to get.
Why would I be upset?
What kind of a Douche bag gets if you
stub
your toe and you go,
oh,
that fucking hurt.
Who gets them out that who the fuck is
wrong to say that's it's a trick.
Yeah.
But if we didn't do that,
then words wouldn't be as powerful as
they are now.
It would be just as powerful.
Do you?
You're like,
Eh,
whatever.
I heard fuck you five times a day.
You hear it was like so exotic word that
nobody used,
like still has a good amount of zing to.
It is the only one you know other than
racial epitaphs.
There has to be a way to turn off the
sensoring thing,
right?
I don't know.
Lazy job.
Is there a way to turn it off?
The social stream appears to be censored
because why would they sensor data,
but yet I could say fuck,
fuck bag right now and it's even worse.
It's how you say it in this man says
what?
I let my kids curse.
Fuck yeah.
It's just words.
Goddammit.
People are so weird.
Wow.
You really are censored.
I don't see a single swear.
No one can swear.
Now everyone has to ride that thing.
I think it's twitter.
It's not twitter.
It's nuts.
It must be ustream.
Yeah,
it's totally username,
but it might be just a second.
You could say anything on twitter.
Okay,
well that dude who I was talking earlier
with,
t h cit and we're giving you a hard time
with the way you wrote something.
I completely apologize Sir.
I was of line.
I did not know that you actually
couldn't write the word fuck and you had
to write all that other nonsense.
My apologies.
All right,
so it does not look like you can turn it
off or at least no one's saying
anything.
Teach that to a kid and have him repeat
it in school.
I don't know what this question was
about,
sir.
Okay.
Well thank you.
Uh,
Austin Curtis Austin.
See Curtis,
because if it wasn't for you we wouldn't
even have known that it is censored.
This guy says the Bible is just rubbish
English people such cool things to say
rubbish.
I mean that sounds fucking some gay
things that they say take a leak,
but you know what my favorite is proper.
You know,
like if something like,
oh that's a proper sports car.
Yeah.
Proper.
That's like that.
I like when they say that there's
something that sounds dope about that.
Now that's a proper cell phone.
No,
you just see it on the telly and telly.
Telly doesn't.
I like England on man.
I enjoyed over there doing comedy with.
It's fun.
Yeah,
they're fucking cool.
You know,
it's like our comedy translates directly
to them.
Shake their comedy.
Doesn't translate the same,
you know,
like their standups don't translate as
some of them make it over here.
I mean obviously I'm a Sacha Baron Cohen
who in my opinion is one of the funniest
guys of all time,
but he's not really established.
Oh my.
He's like crazy prankster.
Hilarious guy.
Yeah.
You see somebody was fucking a chicken
on a subway yesterday and somebody
recorded on video just like,
you know how it saw sat in those.
Oh,
that's one of the signs of the
apocalypse.
Yes it is.
I think it's on d listed.com.
It hard.
How did it get hard?
Oh,
you can say kind of you space it out.
This guy wrote word spaced it out.
You clever bastard.
Just like Battlestar Galactica.
They just start changing the words.
There'll be forking and I like that was
the craziest thing ever on Battlestar
Galactica.
What the frack frack.
Like you could really say that.
I mean,
so it just shows you how dumb it is that
we still have magic words that you can't
say.
Yeah.
People having sex with chickens is
freaky.
Have you seen chicken?
Pork?
Egg Hall is supposed to feel real good.
It's weird that like some animals,
like sheep are supposed to have like a
perfect feeling.
Vagina.
It's supposed to be just like a real
one.
Yeah.
She supposedly.
This is weird.
I know right now is what Jesus is.
Tau Pet sheeps and shit.
This dude is putting this advisee.
The dirty banana says,
my brother in law's a Brit.
I liked when he says proper flucht like
when describing trash.
That's totally how they would say it
might.
I was proper fucked.
Wow.
That's a cool fucking thing to say.
That's.
And you have to say that,
but that's something you have to say
with an English accent and say like,
yeah,
it was.
I was out there.
We were getting drugging.
We got to fucking join God and listen.
I was proper fucked people.
Go what?
I was proper fucked.
Yeah,
and the way they say so much better.
They say constantly fucking cunt.
With a fucking cunt.
Cunt is not as strong over there as it
is over here because they say it all the
time.
It's like they're way more liberal with.
They use the word cut checks a around
all the time who hung out with fucking
counting.
Cigarette counting is a great word when
cons.
Not good enough.
It's counting,
you know,
it's like takes deeper.
It's like you're so,
so bored with St John.
You said con so often.
The n England,
the end of it.
That's all.
That's all hard.
You Roll fucking cutting cigarette.
You know.
You say that man,
that someone's used to car.
I need a smoke a fag.
We need a stoner president that would
get things done.
Supposedly there's a picture of Obama
smoking a joint.
Yeah,
but I don't know if it's a joint count.
Cigarettes,
no way to tell.
He's definitely smoked weed before,
but man,
I don't think there's any way he can be
doing it now.
First of all.
Yeah.
We do need a president that sees other
ways of looking at things.
That's what we need.
Whether a president's a yoga master does
it,
you know,
all naturally or whether our presence of
stoner or whether our presidents.
A guy likes to go into the jungle and
take Iowasca with the Shaman.
We need someone who has a leader's way
of seeing the world,
someone who sees it outside of this
crazy,
predetermined pattern that we're on
right now.
You know,
I mean,
I wrote this article about it's on my
blog about the large hadron collider and
how crazy it is that like at a certain
point in time,
science got to this weird point and I'm
not trashing it in any way because I'm
fascinated by technology.
I'm just making an observation that when
we first started inventing things,
it was to improve the quality of our
life.
You know,
we invented spheres so that we didn't
have to chase after the animals and
vitamin with our teeth.
We invented things.
We never rented houses,
so we're surviving to the rank,
but at a certain point in time it got
completely
past that.
And now even though we have all sorts of
things to deal with with the human race,
like poverty and what's going on in
Haiti and Liberia,
the vice guide to Liberia,
if you haven't seen that document,
God damn these fucking dudes went to
Liberia,
which is this crazy nation in Africa
that has like rampant cannibalism.
Like people are constantly killing each
other and eat each other.
They're selling human meet on the
street.
And this,
I mean,
this one dude talked about he was a
warlord.
They called him general button naked and
this fucking crazy guy would kill babies
and talks about it.
How he would kill innocent children from
the,
uh,
opposing tribe or whoever the fuck they
were at war with,
cut out their heart and they would all
eat the heart and would strengthen them
for battle and make them vulnerable to
bullets.
He ate a lot of people.
And this guy talks openly about eating
people about what you eat.
If you're hungry for hunger,
you eat like the soft part,
like the stomach and the inside of the
thigh because it's tender,
mean.
He's talking about like what you eat.
What part of a person you're talking
about a return,
this guy in who was eating street food,
like you bought some chicken skewers or
something and it was human meat and he
can tell because he's eating it so many
times.
So he explained to the police,
this guy's like serving human food and
you have him arrested and now the guy's
like a crazy a evangelist.
And he like,
he like preaches and fellows.
He's killed thousands of people as the
name of that documentary.
The vice guy to live barrier.
Yeah.
Texts that are twitter that a lot of
people are asking me,
Jesus Christ,
I got gotta took that.
One of the craziest fucking things I've
ever seen.
You know what's weird is that Obama's
still struggles with his cigarette
addiction.
You know,
he's always talking about that.
How he just started back up and stuff,
right?
I'm going to post one of eight have
posted up on twitter right now.
There's,
you,
you got to have to find them.
You know,
if you just,
it's the,
the site is very clunky.
The vice guide site,
these guys that put the site together,
it's um,
they,
they didn't do such a great job putting
the site together,
but the,
but the footage is incredible,
you know,
I mean,
what they're doing is just amazing.
The stuff they're,
they're getting deep into this.
Like Liberia is like literally like a
scene in a horror movie.
Like it's like a lot.
They went to a brothel in Liberia and
it's just like saw.
I mean,
it literally is.
It's hostile.
It's insane and it's real and it's
happening right now.
I'm posting it up on twitter right now.
This is the first one.
This is part one,
but it's you,
you,
you mean it really will change.
The apocalypse is here.
It just hasn't had America.
It's here.
It's in Mexico.
It's in Liberia,
it's in Haiti right now.
It's all over the fucking world.
There's big crazy shit is happening all
over.
The world is not happening in America
yet.
You look at how Liberia is,
that's going to change the way you look
at everything.
And the fact that this could go on today
in 2010 and not even have it be like a
subject like that that makes the 5:00
news,
you know,
that it's more important to find out
some new girl that tiger woods fucked.
You know what I mean?
Really?
There's people in Liberia,
they're eating people on a regular
basis.
It's,
it's,
it's fucking crazy.
Once you watch it's gonna.
If they show up,
they show a guy with the human heart.
They show a kid,
a young kid talking about,
oh,
that's the good meat.
That's the good beat.
The person pd talking about eating your
enemies.
Whoa.
What the fuck man?
It's pretty heavy shit.
Mother fuckers at your home phone on
vibrate.
Right?
What happened?
I Apologize,
Ladies and gentlemen.
My bad came.
I was going to ask you something to me.
Well,
you know what?
You see me everyday,
motherfucker.
Let's get some questions from these
folks know me well.
I've been trying to ask you questions
from these questions.
Okay,
let's go for some.
But in Africa when I was going to ask,
it's a fine line,
ladies,
gentlemen,
between letting the rant come out,
letting the ramble and I want to answer
your questions,
but you know,
every now and then I got something a
rant comes and I think for entertainment
purposes it's best to roll with it.
We got to stand hope lately I have not
seen paranormal activity but I want to
style.
But a while I started talking to him was
probably a couple of months ago.
He was telling me he was going to come
to la.
We're going to try to schedule a
crackle.
The show that never goes anywhere.
We have to do that soon man.
Let's get cracking.
Sign.
Seriously.
Crackle show.
Not Tell people we can't tell you what
it is here.
Do you watch the Pakistan gun market on
thing?
On Vice TV?
No.
I only thing I've seen on vice tv right
now is that Liberia thing.
But that fucking do what those guys are
doing is incredible.
And I've heard this all their videos are
incredible.
Vice Guide to Liberia and again I
posted,
I just posted it on twitter,
but if you just go to vbs.tv,
that's their website and they have so
much different shit there.
It's incredible.
These guys have giant cast iron balls.
I mean this dude drove to this fucking
town in Liberia that's like this shanty
town where there's no electricity.
There's no.
There's a piss and shit in the streets
and this dude and a truck.
They drove in there and people started
yelling,
give us money,
give us our money.
Like it's crazy.
They could have been hacked apart,
alive.
I mean literally it's like a scene in
the Goddamn horror movie.
Oh my God.
Why?
The girl says from the video of champion
monkeys,
because you need to know,
need to know.
Goddammit.
I need to know where that hair came
from.
Things.
My cats here.
Hopefully sneaky bitch tastes like her
hair.
I've had her hair in my mouth.
Um,
questions.
I didn't put up a website thing here on
the message board and usually to do.
Maybe someone could.
Someone's asked questions in the message
board,
get Bravo Indian drunk on eastern.
No,
because this is my house.
The bronto does not.
He's not allowed to drink at my house.
When you have babies,
that's the first thing you want to cut
out as Eddie being drunk in your house.
The sharp corners and knives.
Worried about Eddie being drunk and
you're out.
Just brought this girl sleeps in the
baby room with a honey coming over.
I got this honeycomb and over can sleep
in the crib to he dropped.
Okay.
What's the big deal?
I have a family man.
That's hilarious.
Bom,
Bom.
Mm.
Okay.
Answer a few more questions and we're
going to leave soon because we've been
doing this for two hours and that's how
we're going to keep doing it in the
future.
What we've got to get all.
We got a bunch of one that we're going
to figure out today how to get up on
itunes.
We record just the audio portion of it.
Any News on your website?
I got a crazy website designer who knows
what he's doing.
He's working on some crazy shit when it
comes out.
It's going to be dubbed though,
so I'll leave it for now,
but in the meanwhile,
Brian may build a bridge.
He may build a website to bridge us
between this website in the future
website because he's getting,
he's chomping at the bit.
So what's your,
um,
what is your review page?
Is it a,
what is your zero?
My space is at a.
let's find Jesus.
Yeah,
they're all on red band dot Com.
Or if you just want to check out the
video part of it because I have a
written review and the regular video
review,
but if you go to youtube backslash,
let's find Jesus.
Okay.
But then go to Red Ben Dot Com.
Red Ban r a r e D,
b a n.com.
Seriously,
if you ever want the best review of the
droid I've ever seen as his review,
he breaks down.
I was talking about this today with
customer service.
Like technology hasn't helped us in any
way.
Trying to like when you're on the phone
going no,
d like dog B,
like boy,
there's nothing that has been.
Has been invented to distinguished d's
and B's.
Yeah.
You have to say a Beta Alpha P as in
penis.
You always use
words,
ideas as Dick.
I do.
This guy was getting really annoying and
I was trying to sign up for my,
uh,
my serious,
so I kept using swear words in Shit,
Diaz and Dick and it was like,
okay,
okay.
Okay.
I think it was like he was annoying me,
so I was like,
no,
he was annoying me.
That's hilarious.
It was just being so unhelpful.
Like what I was talking to him.
I'm like,
listen man,
I've been a customer for a long time,
like,
been awkward with me.
So,
uh,
I was holding off for them verizon
iphone since that didn't come.
Should I go with the pre or what should
I do?
Yeah,
I fucked us.
We thought that we were going to get the
uh,
Wednesday announcement.
Yeah,
it was gonna be a new,
um,
I'm going to check a look at the pre
because like I said,
I like this for the phone,
but it's,
it's pretty much a,
you know,
the Prius has,
it has an option to be a,
my fireworks broadcast.
Verizon Network Rail and so if you get
the,
the IPAD,
you could broadcast verizon network and
then connect it.
That's pretty bad ass.
I like the pre to.
I'd like to.
It seems to be as responsive as an
iphone and it seems to be the only one
that video they opened up 50
applications at once.
You can't do that with his fucking
clunky hunter shit.
This is like seriously.
This is like a dumb knockoff from a
third world country and storm to.
Yeah.
Not even like you ever see those fake,
you know the storm to is.
Have you seen those fake iphone?
They make another countries that are
just clunky ass shit.
You know that.
That's what this is like.
It's like it's so beyond.
It's so behind tor to come out yet.
Not yet.
That's what I want to get.
February third,
I believe that comes out of the Palm
Prius because I liked the way the palm
thing slides on the screen is way nicer.
I've always been a fan of palm and it
looks like they got their shit together
on this one.
Did you get your shit together?
I hated the last one.
We had,
remember we all had a trio,
several hundreds or whatever,
but we thought it was the shit when I
first.
Then it started freezing up all that
time and we were like,
yeah,
I think I might get that.
Whoa.
Can we see in your book when it comes
out?
Unfortunately I don't have any fucking
pictures of when I was younger.
Not Very,
very,
very few,
but it was all about,
uh,
the road by doing standup.
When I first started out,
I just got a bunch of crazy stories that
I thought would be a good first book to
write.
You know,
it's just,
it's basically just crazy road gigs,
like trying to make it as a standup
comedian.
You don't realize how strange it is.
Like it's such a crazy life and it's,
you know,
you don't know what's going to happen.
You don't know where you're going.
It's the most,
it's the most unsure way to make a
living,
to try to be a professional stand up
comedian.
Pre is not all that.
I
can't open that many apps.
Why?
What are you talking about?
So what are you talking about?
There's a video of lost.
It's online.
Just go watch the old one.
You couldn't open up that many gaps,
but the pre plus as much more internal
memory to be on top of it.
You had this conversation with Brian
rankled.
The prepress can actually.
There's a video of somebody opening up
50 apps at once and it's still playing
need versus
hey,
you guys should put up a contest for
people to be on your show.
Laziest stalker ever just to haul
Alex Jones.
Agent.
Yeah.
People always want to know that actually
he's Bill Hicks and if that's true,
Stan hope is in Austin today.
He should have stopped in to see Alex
Jones.
Would they get along?
Yeah.
It's their friends and hope hoping.
Alex was friends with both of us.
We all talk about how crazy it is,
but.
But last time Alex Jones get on a stage
or something like that.
Yeah,
that was.
Alex is crazy.
He's a nice guy though.
His name
Alex.
Oh,
I love hanging out with the dude.
He's fun to hang out with.
But every time I ran with the guy,
I always feel bad for him because I feel
like I might just relaxing and calm
down,
you know,
turn off strong.
He doesn't turn off
very high.
Strong father loves the UFC.
Whoever's doing mark cadens.
Not that funny.
Mr.
Angry Amadeus?
No.
The wash.
The state of the Union.
Any thoughts?
I didn't watch it.
Did you watch it?
What state of the Union?
Who Cares?
You know,
it's almost like at this point in time,
I thought that right before Obama got
elected,
you know,
when,
when you know,
it looked like he was gonna win.
I was like,
wow,
this is so crazy.
This guy's gonna win.
Like this really,
really felt like things were gonna
change.
You know?
It really felt like,
wow,
maybe voting is real.
You know,
this guy can get an office.
He's got a black guy from a single mom
and you know,
in the way he says it's going to get
everybody out of Afghanistan and get
everybody out of Iraq.
And meanwhile he doesn't.
Well,
he also said when he was running like,
this is a long road.
You know,
I've got a lot of my room,
he never said it was going to be quick.
Like even when he was,
you know,
he's said this the whole time,
troops to Afghanistan,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not a military expert,
but will we have to look at for real is
we have real problems at home.
We have real mean.
When you look at the enemy,
you look at attacks on America,
like there's this big giant distraction
that the big fear it seems we have to
worry about,
worry about from other nations from all
over the place.
There's a lot of crime and violence in
America that America that we got to
worry about before we worry about crime.
A giant group called the Taliban acting
to kill Americans,
worried about the thousands of people
that we kill every day and how the fuck
do we put a stop to that shit?
How do we put a stop to senseless
violent crime in America?
And then we got to deal with the fact
that we're right next door to Mexico and
Mexico is way crazier than Iraq and
Afghanistan combined.
More people get murdered in Mexico than
anywhere in the world.
The war on drugs in Mexico.
There's five times more casualties this
year.
Some something like that.
Victor Dobela,
the guy who does the,
um,
uh,
the,
the Spanish version of my job for the
UFC.
Great Guy.
He was living in Juarez and he told me
it was some crazy statistic,
you'll have to google it,
but it was like five times more people
died in the war as in one year then died
in the record.
To me,
it's not man,
they're,
they're just killing people left and
right down there.
And the reason why they're doing it is
because there's so much money and
selling illegal drugs.
The United States from Mexico.
I mean,
it's incredible.
These guys get so God to enrich and
they're fighting over so much that the
violence is insane and they're killing
police officers and politicians and they
brought over fucking tanks and shit and
they got tanks running through the
streets in Juarez.
I mean,
this shit is happening literally into a
country that's connected to us.
You can fucking drive there.
It's not,
you don't have to fly halfway across the
world to deal with some conflict,
whereas the enemy is there.
The enemy is anybody who's murdering
people.
Alright.
Anybody who's so fucking crazy,
they're killing five times more people
than die in a war.
I mean,
it's right there.
That's a war.
There's a war that were not even
involved.
It's connected to us.
It's fucking dangerous.
They're getting rich and shit and they
have tanks and who knows what they're
going to get.
I mean,
in Mexico you'd probably buy jets.
You know,
I could probably bicycling fucking US
army jets from Russia.
Who the fuck knows?
They have billions and billions and
billions of.
I mean they're so rich.
It's scary shit,
man.
Very scary shit.
Are worried about what's going on in
Afghanistan,
but the problem is there's money in
there's natural gas,
there's money in oil in Iraq,
there's oil controlling the natural gas
pipeline.
The reason why people have been trying
to get to Afghanistan over and over
again for so many years with the Soviets
invaded them.
Why they're there.
They're trying to get the resources.
Whenever we fuck with other countries,
we're trying to get their resources.
That's it.
In the future of the electric cars,
do you think people are going to be like
blowing up radio shacks and like protect
the radio shack batteries.
Nevermind.
Get that one at all.
You didn't even get it.
The cartel isn't saying.
Yeah,
it is insane,
man.
It's scary shit.
Where do you get.
Can you get this gracie shirt for from.
I got it from a Gracie Jiu Jitsu
website.
I'm not exactly sure what the name of it
is.
What it was that,
that bitch got cut.
That is.
Don't know.
Oh,
that's a girl.
So they beat her up while she was
pregnant.
Is Steven Jackson like a football
player?
Ex-Girlfriend House.
That's why she bears her results being
attacked.
Oh,
attack at the hands of the NFL star.
Oh Shit.
Damn.
Who knows?
She might be crazy.
The variable play quick live.
Yes I have.
It's fucking amazing.
Or La or la Orilla.
What does that mean exactly?
I don't know what that means.
Mexico.
Mexico's guy says,
you know,
it's,
it's crazy that we have countries still.
I mean,
it's crazy lives like an area where if
you're born over here,
you're fucked the shit out of luck.
We don't let you come to the good spot.
It's not like just one planet that we
all live on.
We like separated with guard the borders
and we have fucking guns and shit and
they'll,
you know,
there's like a lot of stories about
border patrol shooting people that are,
you know,
like holding a rock at 100 yards.
You can't hit them with a rock and
headshot him.
He was threatening us like it's pretty
nutty man.
Just because you're on the other side of
the fence.
It's such an uncompassionate thing,
you know,
the,
the whole idea of this,
these team rooms,
you know,
and not allow and everybody says,
well if you let them over,
they would just come over and a swarm
and they would fuck up the whole
culture.
Really within our theory here in La.
I mean,
how many illegals are there in la?
How much more would it be if it was
legal here?
There's some white people.
Do you think everybody would just come
over if they said,
okay,
now there's no immigration.
That's just one country.
The United States,
Canada and Mexico.
Everything that's attached is one
country.
I think what happened,
I think they're just all come up.
There would be nobody in Mexico.
Yeah.
You can get some bad ass deals on houses
in Mexico.
Then it will settle out over a few
generations.
Shit,
you know,
people would realize like Baja
California is pretty fucking the cost of
living here.
It's ridiculous.
I've been looking at loss lately now
because I was at this party in the
studio in a lock and it was amazing.
I was like,
oh,
that's perfect for people.
That has had a lot of shit now like
last.
It's just a big room,
you know,
like it's,
it should be cheaper,
you know,
last start like going to $3,000
out here for just.
It's amazing how expensive laughs are.
Yeah.
No,
it is weird though.
Things are really expensive.
You know,
in cities like New York City apartments
are the nuttiest things ever.
New York City apartments are assets
retire.
You have to be like 3000 bucks for a
little tiny place.
That's lot of people for that mean that
it's impossible to be like a significant
percentage and people go,
well,
you know,
I don't have to have a car because I
take the subway everywhere.
That's all well and good,
but then you don't feel trapped.
No.
You don't feel tethered to this machine.
You really want that.
God dammit.
Dammit.
The North American Union,
this gentleman says Pentair 33.
Yeah,
that's what it's supposed to be.
It's supposed to be a North American
union is supposed to be this fucking
crazy.
How would just describe it?
New World Order conspiracy that we're
moving towards one world government and
of how like in Europe they have the euro
that goes through one one money source
that we're going to do that with the
America and America and you know,
Lou Dobbs actually talked about it on
CNN,
but Lou Dobbs might be crazy.
Obama was really interesting when you
addressed it.
He addressed it during his campaigns,
so he sees no evidence for that and it
makes you wonder like,
how much do you think they really know
how much you think?
I mean,
who the fuck does Obama answer to?
What happens when you actually get an
office?
A cat.
That's the secret.
There's this really smart cat golden
head dress and it just sits there.
Obama,
you must don't make me turn you into
salt,
bitch.
I mean,
what do you think happens when they get
in there?
I mean,
do they meet with the heads of these
gigantic corporation that spends
millions of dollars on their campaign?
They must,
they must,
you know,
I mean that's one of the things that
they said about Bush that Bush met with
the heads of all these different energy
companies,
oil companies and it's like common
practice that like,
or it's common knowledge rather that a
policy was dictated after he had these
meetings.
Like they had worked it out,
but that's what I mean.
How does anybody not expect that?
If you pay people millions of dollars,
you'd give them millions of dollars,
your money to get them into office.
Once they're in office mean you bribe
them,
mean you ride them.
Why would you spend millions of dollars?
I mean if you're an oil company,
why?
Why?
Why are you giving politicians all this
money?
Because you want them to like take it
easy on you.
You want to.
You bribing them.
It's nuts.
I mean it's,
it's crazy that that's legal.
It's great and the Supreme Court
recently just stopped the cap on
spending on it.
They said that they're like,
they treated them as an individual that
are corporations like an individual so
they could spend as much money on
campaigns they want.
That's crazy.
They're going to have all kinds of nutty
as commercials like that talking dog
commercial that they came up with.
Obama has a spending freeze though on on
a lot of the money last week.
I thought that was the whole thing.
I don't know.
He probably talked about it last night.
He was horrified by it.
I'm sure he was talking about it,
but I think that's also just because
people were horrified by it.
I think they just got so greedy and
horrific that they needed to take a step
back and go,
listen,
we fucked up.
This is like,
this is like,
you know,
people might store in the White House
with guns.
This is getting crazy.
Like now,
you know,
even people that run the corporations
are like,
really?
If they're gonna let us do this.
This is,
is this democracy?
Is this really with the United States
was founded on Ustream.
This week doesn't seem like it's been
fucking up as I've been fucking up at
all.
No,
you stream looks fine this week.
Has Anybody have a problem with?
Um,
we were ready to jump ship you dirty
bitch.
And it could have been the storm last
week.
He could have been this,
you know,
Obama Obama did right after the budget's
got increased by 35 percent.
That's what this guy says.
Obama did.
What?
What was the question?
Was saying that Obama put a cap on the
spending.
He did after the budget increased by 35
percent.
So they increased it so they changed it,
but 35 percent and then he put a cap on
it.
So it made it look like he was doing
anything.
Something to stop it.
But really they didn't.
Is that what you're saying?
Well,
it seems like the spending freeze is in
2011.
He said it's all fucking nuts and that's
why I don't follow this stupid.
It's,
it's,
it's so complex.
Politics are so complex that a certain
point in time you have to like look at
your resources.
You have to look at your life and go,
how much time do I have to deal with
this shit?
How much time do I have to take care of
my children to pay my bills,
to manage my career,
to go to the gym,
to hang out with my friends,
to play a couple games of pool?
How much fucking time do you have in a
day?
And that's why they can just fuck you
and keep fucking you.
That's why these cigarette and alcohol
companies get away with contributing
millions of dollars to a partnership for
a drug free America.
And then they make commercials like the
one with the talking dog that,
you know,
tells the girl stopped smoking weed.
It's just corruption and it's blatant
and it's right in front of our eyes.
I mean,
the,
the system is so fucked up that it's
almost like someone else has to come in
and fix it.
It's almost like we're like lord of the
flies,
just a giant,
large scale version of it and we're just
fucking going crazy.
You know,
we're,
we're allowing corporations and these,
these dudes to make millions and
millions of dollars just by fucking us.
The,
the,
all this stimulus money that went to all
these banks and they don't have to
account for.
It's fucking chaos.
I mean,
that is a mad grab for cash where dudes
are saying,
well,
we got to give them their bonuses.
We don't give them their bonuses.
They're gonna leave.
So that's why they should get millions
of dollars of taxpayers money while the
whole economy melt in front of
everybody's eyes.
Like,
that's incredible.
There's so bold that they're wanting,
they want bonuses while everything's
falling apart and going under because
they have contracts and then he said,
well,
we were going to lose them to other
corporations like know what you're
supposed to lose them.
You're fucking bank failed stupid.
Holy Shit.
I mean,
it's amazing how just blatant they are.
It's almost like it's so corrupt that
nothing's going to fix it and I feel
like when I think about investing my
time and trying to pay attention to it
or God for fucking been trying to do
something to fix it,
it's like it's so fucked up.
It would take 100 lives of 100 people
living in 100 lives just to bring it
back to baseline,
just to bring it back to no corruption.
You know?
Politics in America are so fucked up and
corrupt and when I talked to people that
really know about it,
like I know some dudes who run some big
businesses and I've talked to them about
politics,
about what real campaigns and what
contributing is really all about.
It's fucking horrifying.
It's horrifying.
It's,
it should be all illegal.
It should be illegal for politicians to
talk while someone else writes their
speeches totally illegal.
There's no way you should be a guy
reading a God damn script written by 20
experts in,
in,
in English,
and in,
you know,
in the right way to phrase things and
great writers who know how to mimic some
of the responses that people got to
historical speeches,
you know,
like,
well,
Teddy Roosevelt was in a similar
situation.
This is what he said and I think we need
to address that and the founding fathers
of this country really new passed.
We need to address that.
And they calculated so perfectly to make
you interesting.
We don't even know who the fuck Obama
is.
We know that he's pretty cool,
calm and collected,
but you know,
until you see a dude,
you know that until we have.
Obama does,
where a lot.
I was on shit though.
You got to give them that,
but it's all.
Anyway.
If
he was talking like that in your house,
you would think he's crazy.
What we need to do as a nation and as
individuals,
you'd be like,
why can't you just talk to us?
Why?
Why do they have to talk like that?
Why can't they get onstage and go,
listen,
there's a certain age group that's
almost dead,
but once they die,
I think we're going to be like,
I think so too.
I think it's just an age group that,
that if we didn't do that,
then people would be like,
what the fuck?
You know?
Maybe in 30 years the president's going
to be like you are,
you know?
Yeah.
I think you've got a good point.
I think that's real possible in that age
group just got to go and once they're
gone,
weed's going to be illegal.
Everybody before the Internet,
Pre Internet.
Oh my God.
You know,
if you didn't embrace the Internet,
God,
you're just,
you're,
you're riding on a buggy man.
You're riding on an animal.
You know all that.
That,
I mean,
can't we have a president that's,
that gets on stage and talks like a
normal human.
He wraps.
This is the guy who gets on stage.
He goes,
well,
here's our situation.
You ever seen that guy ray kerr rate
Kurt's will explain a technological
singularity and the exponential increase
in technology.
The way he explains it as like a regular
dude.
He's not talking about it like it's the
future.
God bless America and he's not.
He's not getting all crazy and dramatic
and theatrical.
He's just giving you information,
but you could get.
Some people feel like they just have to
do that.
Like Alex Jones even,
but that's.
It's a fake drama.
I don't mind real drama.
I don't mind if the guys talking and if
he.
If I feel like he should have,
and you could tell that sincerity and
that's one of the reasons why they put
on that so obvious fake voice because it
masks insincerity.
That's what's the most offensive about
politician speeches.
When if they had a talk,
if they had to go up there and go,
well,
what I want to do is I want,
first of all,
I want to end this war.
I'm trying to figure out how we've got
to get out of Afghanistan.
First thing we're going to do.
It was going to set up Iraq,
we're going to get out of there and if
he said it like a guy who was just
talking to you,
you will be able to see where the
bullshit is,
but by masking it in political speech,
in that speech,
that mode,
that space against predetermined pairs,
broadcasters and everyone,
we stand at a crossroads,
blah,
and when they talk like that,
it's agreed that it's going to sound
like bullshit and it masks bullshit.
I just thought that up to newscasters.
Totally sweet that.
So I remember because that's a bit.
There's a bit in there somewhere,
right?
Yeah.
That's why they speak speeches like
that.
Because you would.
If they were speaking like a regular
person,
you another fellowship.
Why did the news people on radio
stations have to do it because they're
trying to get that paper pay.
Whatever you did,
there was a fire today.
Check this shit out.
We fill in this on main street.
Look at this building.
That's how fucked up check festival.
It's really hard for people to be
themselves on camera.
It takes a long time.
Yeah,
but they train them to be that way.
They trained them to have that voice.
That's why the weather person and a
traffic person in every city all sound
the same.
In radio,
we have to have the certain data on main
street.
It looks like you got clear sailing on
the floor.
Oh,
five.
Yeah.
They have a certain way of doing it
because that's,
you know,
it's sort of like strip club djs too.
It's like,
yeah,
they're nervous so they fall into this
pattern because it makes them more
comfortable.
Some standup comedian sound like that
too.
You know?
Some comedians like you can tell like
they're trying to sound like a comic.
That was a big thing in the eighties.
There was a bunch of guys who weren't
saying Jack Shit,
but they were saying it like comics and
they would get laughs.
There's a few guys I want to mention
names,
but a,
the eighties was real easy for shitty
comedy.
There's a lot of guys like slipped
through because it was so much comedy
going on.
They never learned how to talk as
themselves.
They're always like the wacky comedy
voice guy.
It's your duty for 20.
Oh,
it's already going on.
For what time?
Is it a third time?
You guys ever talk about Michael
Leonhard appointed the head of the dea?
No,
I don't know.
You know what it's like.
It's the same thing as like open up the
doors to Mexico.
So I,
I,
I don't know the solution.
And the problem with the dea is really.
Yeah,
they shouldn't be busting people for
pot.
Pot should be legal,
but there are some drugs that are
fucking tab before you,
you know,
there's real drugs are terrible for you
and a lot of our salt by fucking
pharmacies.
All right.
How about Oxycontin?
You got real problems.
What's that thing we were talking about
earlier?
The oxycontin express,
but these dea guys and all this,
they have families,
they have jobs,
you know,
and this is what they're doing and a lot
of them signed up to do the right thing
to try to protect communities and then
they get involved in it.
And I think that's when things get
squirrely and you know,
you,
you do realize that yeah,
it is kind of fucking silly that I could
tell a guy can't do this,
I'm going to lock them in a cage.
And you think you're doing okay because
you're just doing your job.
Well.
If they make pot legal fit,
that's 50 percent of the bulk of people
are in prison for nonviolent drug
offenses.
Do you just immediately cancel out all
their other,
their,
their cases and let them out?
Or do you say?
No,
you live in the dark ages so you're
fucked.
You know,
you lived in the ages when it was
illegal.
I mean you'd have to let everybody out
of jail.
He'd have to let like half the people
out of jail.
Well that's,
that's crazy.
They're all fucked up now.
They've been in jail and they're all
harden.
Had been there for five years and
they're fucking angry unless you're
going to pay him how you gonna let him
out of jail.
You're going to give them millions of
dollars.
They've got all sue.
Okay?
So now you got millions of people who
want millions of dollars.
You don't think the economist.
Fuck now let people that make pot
illegal or make pot legal.
Let people out of jail make the dea
closed down because you're not going to
go after drugs.
Fuck.
It's like the web we have already woven
is so polluted.
It's so hard to.
To extract yourself from it.
Is that the right word?
I'm trying to be smart to be immaculate
with my structure of my linguistics.
You're doing the fake speech thing.
Speech thing.
What's the sickest thing you've ever
seen?
You brother?
What does that mean?
What is the sickest thing I've ever
seen?
I've seen some tech sick things.
Have you been at the Ronald Reagan
Museum here in California?
Um,
no I haven't.
And she'd go pretty crazy.
Really baked and go see her crazy.
The people,
like when I was a kid,
Ronald Reagan was a hated man when
really can't.
Yeah.
Because people have convenient memories.
When I was a kid,
amongst anybody who's intelligent,
I lived in Boston,
which is a fairly liberal,
very intelligent town.
Very,
you know,
high amount of ecologists per capita
people,
Pretty God damn smart and Boston and
growing up there.
They hated Ronald Reagan were all that
Iran Contra Shit was going on and they
made Reagan testify about selling Oliver
North.
I can't recall.
You know,
when it was salt the arms to Iran?
I can't recall.
I don't recall.
You don't recall.
Let me eat whatever the fuck you talking
about.
He just sit up there and say,
I don't remember.
That means you did you fuck you fucking
criminal.
That guy's a criminal.
I mean that guy was your old.
Tell him you don't remember.
I can't recall.
That's crazy.
There's a do Nima.
Jimmy tingle.
It was a hilarious Boston comedian who
had a great joke about that.
He goes,
if you.
Here's a tip,
Mr Reagan,
if you sell ams to people who hate us,
jot it down.
He goes,
make a little note.
Put on your refrigerator today.
I sold homes to people who hate us.
No,
you fucking felt these savages.
I think we're going to end this because,
uh,
we don't want to overstay our welcome
for your 4,000,
the perfect 4,001
viewers,
listeners,
uh,
you guys are super cool.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We will continue this every week.
This is,
I believe five weeks in a row and you
can always get them.
You can always download them off this
huge stream channel and we are going to
look into today how to,
what,
how the fuck would get everything on
itunes.
And then eventually what I would like to
do is I would like to do two of these a
week,
maybe one video and we'll do that and
put it might do one just straight audio.
I'm thinking tool.
We could be better than one.
I don't want to do it like a regular
thing and habits so that you can rss it
and subscribe to it and get it
automatically downloaded to your itunes
and all that jazz.
Fuck Flash.
So that's what we're doing.
Dog.
You had Brian.
It's not worth it.
He knows what he's doing.
Use Flash,
Brian,
you scumbag things are getting crazy.
Alright,
thank you very much guys.
We really appreciate it.
And uh,
we'll see you next week later.
Yo.
Oh yeah,
I'm doing this right.
The people are still here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we will now broadcast only an audio.
This is
the secret session that nobody told
anybody about that because you decided
to stick around and keep your fucking
ustream open.
You're here,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to keep this bumping.
Let's fuck.
We're gonna.
Fuck my cat.
And we're going to talk for another 20
minutes folks.
Why?
Because this is a God damn experiment.
I want to see how many people stay on
people to see how many people listen to
us with just a,
just a backbeat and Brian making cat
noises.
We're down to three.
Oh nine folks.
It's not looking so good with losing
viewers.
I think we do our best work in the,
um,
post anyway.
You know,
people don't have to watch it live to be
honest.
We're not answering questions.
Okay.
Questions are coming in like a waterfall
and we're trying to keep up with.
What's most important is that we give
you the flow.
You know what I'm saying?
We can be the rant.
We talked to you.
We can dictate what are.
What's going on.
Committed.
I'm committed to you.
My friend Adam.
We are committed to Jesus in space.
I'm as high as Paula Abdul is on the
ride home from the pharmacy.
Alright,
you guys are still here.
We've got three.
Oh,
three bitches.
We lost.
We lost people with itchy trigger
fingers.
It's like when you go to and sometimes
you go to the movies and these stop sit
through the credits,
but there's some funny shit next credits
like bachelor the bachelor or the
Bachelor party that's just called Fast
Bachelor party.
That fucking movies.
Alpha nachis moving.
No,
no.
It's a hangover.
Hangover.
The hanger talking Seventies.
Jesus.
I don't even know what I'm talking
about.
I was about a bachelor parties.
The hangover,
my apologies.
That Galifianakis movie.
The fucking.
The end credits or some of the funniest
shit.
I mean,
it's really,
really hilarious.
Hilarious stuff.
So that's what this is.
This is the end credits.
Three.
Oh,
five,
three.
Oh six.
We're gaining.
Maybe it's a gentleman.
Spread the word.
Let bitches know this visual,
but there is a funky beat and they
asked,
still talking and this guy says,
I'm on here.
Twenty four slash seven.
I don't sleep.
Wow.
Ernie,
Ernie am slander in wild man.
Pet my cat for me.
Listen,
I can't want to want to put my cat.
You fucking Weirdo can't for you.
I pet my cat from her.
Okay.
You like a Funky beat?
Yeah.
I liked that music man.
This guy says I like radio better than
video.
Personally.
Imagination.
I agree with you.
I think there is something about that.
I like listening to the radio too,
man.
I love satellite radio for that very
reason.
You know,
satellite radio is the shit but this is
basically satellite radio for everyday.
I don't even have to pay for it,
you know?
I mean I think satellite radio is
awesome and I have in my car,
I have a serious with the best of Xm so
I can get Howard stern and I get opie
and Anthony and I get bubba the love
sponge and I can get,
you know,
Ron Affairs and I can get potus
politics.
I can get anything.
It's fucking awesome.
I love it.
So because of that,
um,
you know,
I think,
I think what this is though,
what this is,
is even more exciting because this is
like radio than anybody can do.
I mean Brian and I are just sitting here
in my living room and we got this
fucking microphone that we bought at the
Mac store and this is connected to our
laptops.
I mean,
so Goddam easy.
We don't have a crew and you know,
I mean if we were charging you guys a
lot of money and we'd had,
you know,
we wanted to have some sort of a
production value to this thing.
Yeah,
I can understand that.
But is that,
does that make it any better when you
watch the tonight show?
So you really give a fuck that there's a
room full of people there and
everybody's cheering and do you read?
You really give a fuck?
There's a band.
They're playing wack ass music.
The at the intros and Outros.
I mean when I,
what I like about like if I watched
Letterman,
I like letterman interacting with
people.
He's funny.
He's a fucking funny guy.
That's what I like.
He could be doing that in his house and
it would be just as interesting.
What are you doing?
You're showing people pictures.
Going to Duncan trussell's facebook
page.
Tonight is Thursday.
Comedy is dead to Django.
Not a good comment.
Got a hot date with the wife.
I had a good comics.
Take her to it.
Um,
no.
I don't want to poison my,
my future baby with.
Oh,
that a good lineup.
Damn.
Doug Benson,
Dana Gould,
Chris Hardwick.
Nick,
no.
Nick Kroll guy.
Branum Duncan trussell and Natasha
Leggero.
That's a good guy.
Yeah.
Duncan puts on a good show.
That's that one that he does from the
funeral and cemetery tonight.
That's nutty.
AP.
We're promo and people.
Man.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we've got an allegiance to our
friends,
but I came out that here's your $2.
You guys are fagging out now that
there's no video,
right?
Listen Fella,
just because you have to use your
imagination to masturbate to the sound
of my voice now and you can't see our
pretty faces doesn't mean we're fagging
out because there's no video.
We're experimenting my friend.
How weird is that?
You guys are fagging out now or are you
meaning that we're fagging out like,
like Brian Sucking my cock right now
when he's talking.
No,
that's not what's going on at all.
I'll let you see a little video real
quick.
As long as you promise to stop being
mean.
Promise no stopping me and I'll let you
see a little more video.
Fuck you.
This is radio bitch.
This is the youth stream radio portion
of the program.
We're down to 300 viewers.
Latest gentlemen.
A lot of people don't like the whole
imagination thing down with it.
Like,
listen,
stupid.
I want to see you get out of here.
This guy says it was a joke,
Joe.
I know it was a joke.
I was joking back.
My friend Andrew Lawrence.
I'm just being silly.
I know.
That's the problem,
man.
You know?
You know you don't know me.
You listen to me talk shit.
I'm an Avatar is horrible.
How dare you.
Irish temper 69.
First of all,
anybody that has a 69 and their name.
I'll have to think about your opinion
and go one of two.
Why was cocksucking looking at below
jobs?
There's nothing in front of me
going to be harder than this.
Turned to a gay off.
Listen man,
you're.
Unless you're 12 years old,
don't have 69 at the end of your name.
And if you are 12 years old and I'm 69
at the end of your name,
who touched you?
Who did that to you?
Or do you just trying to be silly?
You're just trying to be silly.
Irish temper.
I got an Irish temper and I have my
degree yet complete.
Alright,
I'm gonna.
Turn this off.
I won't be happy unless you call me
Aaron instead of earning.
Oh my apologies.
I did not mean that.
Aaron.
Aaron,
them slender.
That's what it is.
I'm sorry.
It's a checklist.
And Gentlemen,
women are very sensitive.
They have to be.
They raise babies.
Okay.
You don't realize that until you have a
few,
like,
oh,
now I know why they're like that because
I'm not milking any fucking baby.
You know what I'm saying?
You need the softer personality.
Brian and Brian Understanding you're
trying to have a baby.
Is this true?
Yes.
Uh,
I'm joining a pregnancy pack where me
and my guy friends were all getting
together and there's this place in
Pennsylvania with these girls that don't
want to have babies in highschool.
Put that away.
I don't want to watch this chicken a
fucking foot job.
Turn that off.
Know this was my house.
Okay.
You're fucking for you to do this.
Totally complete desensitized by the
Internet sitting here hanging out,
and he just puts on some video the CIC
jerking a guy off with her feet.
Really?
That's okay.
Don't even think twice.
Like was there any kids in the room?
I'll fuck it.
You just have that running in the
background all the time while you're
working for.
And I was just going to show it because
like,
who likes that shit?
Some people must.
Some people must be so desensitized.
They must have porn going while they're
working,
like spreadsheets right next to it.
Is that asked for a second.
Second.
Yeah.
You saw it for a second bitch.
You know we're not sucking cock now,
right?
So you cut it with a gay jokes,
man.
It's really not right down to 295 loyal
listeners.
Ladies and gentlemen
to 95 were clear.
This room back to two 96 coming on
strong.
It's coming back.
I'm not even tweeting this.
We were trying to get Eddie for the show
for today.
Yes,
my friend Andrew Lawrence.
But uh,
Eddie is in a plane right now on the way
to Japan chem trails all the way chem
trails like a motherfucker.
I,
our buddy,
uh,
should get.
D is fighting and king of the cage and
Okinawa.
So while they have to fly over there to
um,
to see the fights,
is it awkward looking into Goldie's
eyes?
No
gold.
He's my boy.
He's a good man.
It's a.
that's one of the cool things about
doing the UFC.
He was.
Mike Goldberg was telling me that he had
a Gig once upon a time,
there was a dream gig was an awesome
Gig,
but he hated his partner.
Did Not like the guy,
so the guy was a deck and then gold is
one of the nicest guys I've ever met.
He's such a nice guy.
Mike Goldberg is.
I mean,
you know,
people say fucks up a lot,
like the fucking guys done a hundred and
20 fucking UFC is going to be fuck ups.
You're going to be able to like go back
in and you know,
and Youtube it and make a nice clip of
him.
Fuck it up for sure.
But who cares?
He's a nice fucking guy.
He does the job.
He gets in there,
who knows?
He knows what the fuck is going on.
He makes it happen and he's a cool dude.
I like him.
He's a super friendly guy so it helps me
working with a nice car like that.
It's like I look forward to seeing them
on cast is the new radio.
I think it is,
man.
I really do.
I think that this is the future.
I think,
you know,
I think that what the role,
the only thing that's separate from from
regular radio is you don't have this in
your car yet and that's common.
They've already come up with Internet
capable,
a car,
a car stereos,
and you're going to be able to download
podcasts directly to it and a lot of
people,
they have setups in their car where they
have an ipod and the just.
They download people's podcasts on their
ipod than they set up where they,
the blog broadcast a ipod through their
car stereo speaker of you have that
right?
I sit in my car and it
romantically connects to my iphone and
then I had my whole itunes on my iphone
play through my sink on Ford.
I see.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's the God damn future and it's
going to be just like a dvr.
So you know how you get,
you know your TV shows.
I mean,
how often do you watch tv shows when the
air only if you're home and you look at
forward to it like lost or something
like that and they sit through the
commercials,
but it's way better to not do that.
It's way better to do it whenever you
want it and to be able to control it and
fast forward it.
And if you can download this as an MP
three,
that's the shit.
You're in the car and you're like,
all these dumb motherfuckers were
talking about mma again.
Leads fast forward five minutes what
he's talking about.
You know what I mean?
You can do whatever you want with it.
It's yours.
You got it and you control what you want
to pause it.
You can do that.
You don't miss anything.
You want to rewind it.
You can do that.
How many times have you been listening
to someone talk on the radio and they
say some,
but you don't know what the fuck they
said.
You tried to write it down.
You don't have anything in your car.
You're in traffic.
How cool would it be?
The rewind the radio while you can with
this,
this is way superior than just
broadcasting shit.
Plus there's not signals in the air that
killed the bees
cassette tapes for life.
Yeah.
Because that's.
All right.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
I think that's about it.
Yeah.
I think we're gonna end this because
Brian is tired and it's already 4:40.
So this is two hours and 40 minutes
ladies and gentlemen.
So we gave you an extra 10 minutes of
actual fake radio silence with bubbles
and the whole deal.
You know what I'm saying?
Do I get any inspiration?
Let me answer this stuff.
Did you a lot of inspiration from this,
from your interactions with Tom Green
yet?
That word,
I don't know if this thing's moving so
fastly and his stuff.
This is food foods and spork shit.
It's moving so fast.
It's hard to fall a chat.
Um,
yes,
definitely.
We did a,
I did Tom Green show once and it's
fucking awesome.
He's got this cool ass house where his
whole house is basically like a,
a.
He turned into a studio.
He's got this killer setup where he's
got like servers in his house.
I mean his house is really like the
center of it all.
It's like we're using ustream.
Ustream obviously has,
you know,
some servers set up somewhere,
but we're just kinda connected to them
and broadcasting to you.
Tom Green's got that shit all out of his
house.
Just really kind of a crazy expensive
way to do it.
Well,
it made sense before all these websites,
like ustream came around.
Now it's kind of like,
well you didn't have to do it and how's
Tom Ratio doing?
And people still watching it.
Uh,
I think it's paid for via now or
something like that.
I think he's,
the paper view is the,
um,
the footage,
the archives,
and I think it's hard to figure out how
to make money with this stuff,
you know,
that's what it is with these guys like
Tom Green trying to figure out how to
make money with it,
you know,
I think it's kind of tricky.
He's doing comedy now.
He's doing standup comedy tours,
so yeah,
we got a lot of inspiration from all
this stuff.
There's a lot of cool shit on the
Internet,
you know,
the Internet is where I spend a lot of
my time.
It's what Brian spends a lot of his
time.
And uh,
we,
we think that this is the future.
I mean,
I just got a thing for my car,
uh,
yesterday I got a new car yesterday.
I got an m three BMW,
m three is the shoot and um,
I got a thing where I can hook up my
ipod to it.
It's awesome.
So my playlist showed up in the,
on the,
on screen the screen and I could scroll
through it and pick songs and why it's
so much better than the radio.
It's awesome.
You know,
it's just,
you can control.
I mean,
you can have so much shit.
There's so many interesting things.
You download books on tape,
there's so much shit you can throw out
an Ipod,
you know,
instead of like scanning through the
radio.
It's like,
I mean,
you don't even get a guide.
It's like,
it's like watching the TV by just
flipping the channels,
you know,
you kind of know what's going to be on
because you're memorized it.
Do you have all these gay apples and
medical later.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much and we will see you
next week.
Next week.
We're going to try to do it on Wednesday
and like I said,
we're going to have the shit up on
itunes soon.
And uh,
thank you very much.
She had.